So, auf geht's. Let's go.
Hast du eigentlich deinen Homestalker noch? Ja klar.
Soll ich sonst meinen ganzen Kram drauflaufen haben? Oh, was ist das da oben rechts?
Kegweight.
Was ist das da oben rechts? Ah, das ist noch von gestern.
Die Kamera, die ich eingeblendet habe vom Bastel.
Bastel-Egge.
Ah, die kommt mal weg. Ja, hab ich noch. Wieso?
Welchen meinst du davon? Also aktuell habe ich den Egypt-
Ja, ich bin nicht so wirklich glücklich mit Unraid, aber mit dem ganzen anderen Scheiß auch nicht.
Also es ist wirklich doof, dass es nix
simples irgendwie
gibt für einen Heimbereich. Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin fast schon davor, mir auch ein Kubernetes-Cluster daheim zu bauen und einfach YAML zu erstellen.
Aber dann hast du wieder Probleme, wo machst du deine VMs?
Du kannst zwar prinzipiell das auch in Kubernetes laufen, aber das ist aber auch schon wieder irgendwie sinnlos.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, ich lasse es einfach so wie es ist.
Nee, also ich habe immer noch die HP-Kiste ist es, glaube ich. Oder Dell? Nee, HP. HP, Micro, Server,
Gen, irgendwas. Keine Ahnung, der aktuelle halt.
Ja.
So ein Teil habe ich immer noch.
Gen 10 plus V2.
V2. Ich glaube, V2 habe ich noch nicht. Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen V1 und V2?
Haben die irgendwo... Jetzt nervt nicht rum, Alter. Haben die irgendwo vielleicht eine Beschreibung, was da für eine CPU drin ist?
Ja, das stimmt schon, aber du musst dich da trotzdem um so viel Zeug selbst kümmern. Man könnte auch ESX nehmen, man könnte auch irgendwie
irgendein Kubernetes,
also irgendein OS nehmen, was so schön packaged. Aber das ist alles so viel Aufwand.
Also Unraid ist gar nicht so übel, was das angeht. Du hast eine simple Oberfläche für VMs und Container,
aber so wirklich der weiße als letzter Schluss ist es auch nicht.
Ey, heiß nicht. Ist komisch, das für einen Heimbereich. Also am einfachsten fährt man im Heimbereich, glaube ich, echt, wenn man sich ein Synology NAS kauft.
Was ist denn jetzt der Unterschied zwischen V2? Okay, Microserver, Gen, V2 versus V1.
Ja, Just Spotted. Ich auch.
Okay, warum ist Reddit eigentlich kaputt?
Seit gestern? So lahm?
Okay, der internal USB-Port ist 3.1. Ja, das interessiert mich nicht so, okay.
TPM, okay, Integrate. New Options are new. Okay, es gibt neueren Pentium, New Gears, also...
Okay, es hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Ja, da hat er recht. Ich behalte das Ding jetzt, bis es auseinanderfällt oder ich irgendwas besseres finde.
Ich weiß auch nicht. Ganz ehrlich, ich bin echt über den Heimbereich, was so
Self-Hosting-Sachen angeht,
nicht ganz glücklich. Es gibt zwar immer mehr, aber ich habe noch nichts gefunden, was ich so richtig gut finde.
Ist genauso mit Monitoring für daheim. Ich habe seit einer ganzen Weile ein Zabbix, weil es immer noch die beste Kombination ist aus
Du kannst alles mögliche überwachen
und musst nicht allzu viel selbst machen.
Aber selbst das ist scheiße.
Irgendwie, manchmal muss ich ehrlich sagen, da kommt der Boomer durch, manchmal denke ich mir so, ey, die Zeiten, wo es nicht 30 Milliarden Tools gab
und keins hat dich so richtig überzeugt,
war fast besser zu Zeiten, wo es nur 1-2 Tools gab. Die haben dich zwar auch nicht so richtig überzeugt,
aber du wusstest, du musst die nehmen oder du hast gelitten.
Ja, das habe ich, das reicht mir aber nicht. Das kann ja wirklich nur
Reporten ist up oder down. Das kann weder Checks über SSH, noch hast du eine History beispielsweise, was Plattenplatz angeht und ordentliche
Benachrichtigungen sind auch ein bisschen eklig. Also wobei, das noch am ehesten geht. Es ist auch nicht
für mich sinnig gewesen. Nämlich, ich habe immer noch ein Zabbix am Start.
Die Stromkosten gehen bei mir tatsächlich. Mein Rack braucht
80 Watt oder so und da ist alles drin. Die Fritzbox, die Unity Media Router, mein Switch, mein Server.
Ein Raspberry Pi,
ein Router. Also 80 Watt Idle ist schon vollkommen in Ordnung für das ganze Ding.
Alleine schon der Switch braucht 15 Watt.
Der Homeserver wird Idle auch 20 Watt brauchen.
Dann noch die ganzen anderen. Das ist vollkommen ok. Wahrscheinlich sogar mittlerweile weniger. Ich habe nämlich gar nicht mehr gemessen seit dem neuen.
Achso, keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung. Ich würde mal sagen, das, was man so standardmäßig im Durchschnitt bezahlt, werde ich auch bezahlen. Ich weiß nicht, was sind so die Durchschnittspreise aktuell.
Weiß nicht.
Wie findest du den Mini-PC?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich schicke mal einen Link zu. Also ich habe einen Mini-PC hier von Minisforum.
UM690 Minisforum.
So einen Teil habe ich bei mir.
Warum auch immer die zusammenstehen, aber so sieht das so sieht das aus.
Ich vermute... Ah hier, hier.
Den da.
Den habe ich aber als Emulationskonsolen-Ding.
Ich glaube in Kombination mit
32 GB
und einer 512 GB SSD. Aber ich habe noch eine zweite SSD eingebaut.
Hongkong.
Ja, so einen Teil habe ich.
Mini-PCs Geeko. Ich kann mir das mal angucken.
Sagt mir jetzt so erstmal nichts.
Beste Mini-PCs. Na, wenn der Hersteller das sagt, dann muss das schon stimmen. Sind wir uns ja einig drüber.
Hersteller sagen prinzipiell ja immer die Wahrheit über ihre Produkte.
Die sehen auf dem Bild gar nicht so mini aus, die Dinger.
Haben ganz gute Anschlüsse hier. Ordentlich viel USB.
HDMI, sogar ein Displayport-Output. Vorne noch ein paar USBs, USB-C.
Anschluss für Mikrofon.
Und an Hardware drinnen. Ja, kostet ungefähr das gleiche wie den Mini-PC, den ich habe. In ungefähr der gleichen Konfiguration.
Ja.
Macht doch ganz brauchbaren Eindruck.
Ist halt die Frage, wie die Geräuschentwicklung ist. Das bei so einem Mini-PC. Wobei der ganz schön
PPoFat aussieht.
Für einen Mini-PC.
Ist halt die Frage, wie die Geräuschentwicklung ist. Das müsste man tatsächlich mal in einem Test nachlesen, aber ansonsten macht es auch einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Hast du Tipps für Einsteiger im Linux-Bereich? Home-Projekte oder ähnliches?
Das ist ein bisschen die Frage, auch wie, ob ich Einsteiger-Empfehlungen habe oder was man als Programmierprojekte machen kann.
Und da sage ich jetzt einfach mal die Standardantwort, die ich da immer dafür habe.
Wurde das Stream gestern nicht gespeichert? Nee, ich habe den Stream gelöscht, weil
ich habe die letzte Stunde, ich fand das übelst langweilig, ich habe die letzte Stunde, ohne dass man richtig was gesehen hat, an
dem Thermostat rum gebaut.
Das ist langweilig. Das schmeiße ich weg.
Hast du Tipps für den Einsteiger? Also, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, also das gleiche wie bei Software-Projekten.
Wichtig ist, dass du dir erstmal überlegst, welcher Bereich interessiert dich. Weil das hat ja keinen Sinn.
Sagen wir mal, du interessierst dich jetzt vielleicht für irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten und ich sage dir,
schließe ein paar Sensoren an Raspberry Pi an, so.
Also, das sind ja zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe. Da langweilst du dich und du denkst dir, so ein Scheiß, was soll ich damit?
Weil du lieber Cloud-Sachen bauen willst, anstatt irgendwelche Sensoren an deinen Raspberry Pi anschließen.
Also, du musst dir erstmal überlegen, was du eigentlich machen willst, in welchem Bereich, was dich interessiert. Also, was interessiert dich denn?
Ansonsten, wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast und einfach ein bisschen
dich mit Linux auseinandersetzen willst, dann würde ich sagen,
scheiß erstmal auf Raspberry Pi, Server und sonst was, installiere eine VM
mit Linux drauf, deiner Wahl, Mint, Ubuntu und versuch das mal für tägliche Aufgaben ein bisschen zu verwenden.
Das ist in einer VM vollkommen okay, solange du nicht gerade Videos encoden willst oder irgendwie viel
4K-Videos gucken willst oder so in der VM. Wenn du ein bisschen nicht mit Linux auseinandersetzen willst, installiere dir das in der VM
und versuch da mal tägliche Aufgaben mit zu erledigen.
Das nächste ist, installiere dir einen Arch-Linux, du kannst den Arch-Installer verwenden und richte dir das mal so ein, dass dir das gefällt.
Also, sprich, installiere eine grafische Oberfläche, am besten natürlich i3, by the way, weil i3 ist der einzige, die einzige
ja, der einzige Desktop, kann man ja nicht korrekterweise, kann man das ja so nicht nennen.
i3 ist die einzige grafische Oberfläche, die mich nicht abfuckt unter Linux, also deswegen benutze ich halt i3.
Wenn du das alles eingerichtet hast, so dass es dir gefällt und du das für tägliche Aufgaben benutzt,
also von, kopiere mal ein paar Dateien auf einen USB-Stick, oder ich gucke mal im Internet schnell was nach,
vielleicht installierst du dich auch für irgendwelche bisschen Sachen, Skripten,
wenn du das alles über deine VM machst und Windows erstmal nur benutzt für das, wo es halt auch wirklich sinnvoll ist, was nicht gescheit unter Linux geht,
zum Beispiel irgendwelche Ladder-Games, League of Legends, irgendwas, was die Leute gerne machen, Valorant, was auch immer,
zu spielen, zu streamen, Videoschnitt und sonst was, wo du nicht unter Linux klarkommst, das machst du mit Windows.
Rest machst du unter Linux und dann hast du ungefähr so einen Setup irgendwann wie ich am Start,
ich glaube das funktioniert mittlerweile gar nicht mehr, sudo rm-rfslash, ich glaube die haben da mittlerweile eine Sicherheitsvorkehrung eingebaut,
dass das nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich glaube da sagt ihr, wenn du rm-rfslash machst, so wollen sie das wirklich machen.
Ich glaube du musst no-preserve-root oder sowas eingeben sogar, dass das funktioniert.
Und dann wirst du dann irgendwann zu so einem Setup wie ich hier übergehen, dass du hier deine VM hast und hier dein Windows.
Und wenn du das alles ordentlich eingerichtet hast und das täglich benutzt, dann lernst du viel über Linux.
Gerade so im normalen Handling und Kommandozeilen-Handling und so die Standardbefehle, die man braucht und bestimmt auch schon das ein oder andere Bash-Skript und lernst halt die Sachen.
Besser als sich gleich irgendwie einen Server hinzustellen mit Diensten drauf, auf die man sich verlässt.
Besser ist, du installierst eine Linux-VM und versuchst da einfach täglich ein bisschen mit zu arbeiten und die Sachen so zu lösen, die du halt so an Problemen hast.
Das ganze erstmal unter vrmrworkstation auf deinem Windows-Rechner gemacht.
Ja klar, siehst du auch hier, guck mal.
Das ist vrmrworkstation, da.
Was heißt erstmal? Immer!
Ich finde das ist das beste Setup.
Gibt zwar Leute, die widersprechen mir da.
Ich erinnere mich noch an das eine YouTube-Video, wer auf mein Video reaktet hat.
Wo dann sogar einer bei mir in den Kommentaren geschrieben hat, Max, den musst du verklagen!
Ich hab auch gedacht, was ist mit euch los? Das Video war doch vollkommen normal.
Aber Hauptsache erstmal random Leute verklagen auf YouTube.
Gut, scheint ja mittlerweile Gange und Gebe zu sein, weil ich so wieder mitgekriegt hab die letzten Wochen auf YouTube,
dass sich irgendwelche YouTuber untereinander abmahnen und dann reagieren 50.000 andere YouTuber drauf,
wo dann wieder rauf reagiert wird und die Ursprungs-Reaction-Leute reakten auf die Reactions.
Alter, das ist echt nicht mehr in Ordnung.
Also, YouTube-Deutschland ist so für'n Arsch aktuell.
Oder was heißt aktuell? Die letzten Jahre über schon.
Wobei ich sagen muss, also ich hab den Eindruck, dass YouTube-Deutschland besonders beschissen ist.
Wobei man sagen muss, YouTube-International ist wahrscheinlich genauso beschissen.
Kriege ich aber nicht so oft empfohlen.
Vielleicht, weil ich einfach nicht diese ganzen Channels gucke.
Was hast du für ein Terminal-Theme?
Ein selbstgebautes.
Also, basierend tut das Ganze auf Tomorrow Night.
Also, kannst dir das hier angucken, guck mal.
Auf Wubblos GitHub.
Ah, mein Auge juckt.
So, Wubblos GitHub.
Gehst du hier in meine ZSHRC.
Ne, Quatsch. Nicht ZSHRC.
Was erzähl ich denn für'n Mist?
Das ist in mein Terminal-Config.
Da siehst du's.
Und da ist mein Colorscheme.
Das hält sich tatsächlich in Grenzen.
Das ist mein Farbschema.
Hier. Alles, alles.
Man...
Also, es basiert auf Tomorrow Night.
Aber ich hab ein paar Sachen angepasst.
Von dem standardmäßig included in Tomorrow Night.
Ein paar Sachen hab ich angepasst.
Ich glaube, eine Sache, die ich angepasst hab,
ist die Cursor-Color.
Die Selection-Color.
Dass die nicht so kacke aussieht.
Und...
Genau. Cursor-Color.
Selection-Color.
Und ansonsten, glaub ich,
war's das,
was ich angepasst hab.
Also, das ist das Terminal-Theme.
Und das hier ist Starship.
Und da gibt's auch...
Hier. Starship-Tommel.
Ja. Da hast du den ganzen Kram.
Das ist...
Aber ich hab mir das nicht
komplett selbst ausgedacht.
Ich hab als Basis
das hier genommen.
Das Preset, was dabei ist.
Pastel-Powerline.
Was wiederum selbst auf M365-Princess basiert.
Was auch immer.
Wer die Dinger so benennt.
Aber ich hab das umgebaut
von einem einstelligen Prompt
zu einem zweizeiligen Prompt.
Weil ich weiß nicht, wie's bei euch aussieht.
Ich hab, glaub ich, schon ein paar Mal gefragt,
ob ihr lieber einzeilige Prompts
oder zweizeilige Prompts mögt.
Ich glaube, das ist so 50-50.
Ich persönlich mag zweizeilige Prompts.
Und das liegt ganz einfach daran,
zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt mal hier
in irgendeinen Sub-Ordner gehen.
Ja. Gehen wir mal hier in irgendeinen Sub-Ordner,
wo wir relativ viel Ordner haben.
Dann kann man hier den Ordner sich anzeigen lassen,
wo man gerade drin ist.
Sogar hier fühlt das zu lang.
Dann kann man hier die Infos anzeigen lassen,
wie die Node-Version, auf die das aufbaut.
Oder gehen wir mal hier in ein .NET-Projekt.
Dann sieht man hier das Verzeichnis,
Git-Branch, installiertes .NET,
Target.NET-Version
und sowas in der Richtung.
Und stellt euch mal vor,
das wäre alles nur einzeilig.
Dann könnte ich hier jetzt erst schreiben.
Und hier hab ich noch die Uhrzeit.
Also, das ist wirklich mega kacke.
Deswegen hab ich einfach das Ganze zweizeilig gemacht.
Und man hat immer Platz an der gleichen Stelle
und weiß, wo man hingucken muss.
Außerdem hat man eh genug Space im Terminal.
Also, ich mag zweizeilige Prompts.
Und dann hab ich noch ein bisschen die Schriftart geändert
und ein paar Sachen angepasst.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
ist das gar nicht so viel Unterschied.
Dazu.
Das ist die Kombination,
was ich in das Shell und Terminal eingerichtet habe.
Kennst du BTOP? Ja, haben wir sogar installiert.
Das Einzige, was man einstellen sollte bei BTOP,
ist, dass der den Hintergrund vom Terminal benutzt
und nicht den eigenen Hintergrund.
BTOP.
Brauch ich aber nicht so sehr, weil
guckt mal
wenn ich jetzt
oder mal anders
ich hab hier oben ja
wenn ich ein bisschen Last im Terminal
guckt euch mal das hier oben an
verursache
das ist meine CPU-Kernauslastung.
Das reicht mir meistens.
Ganz ehrlich, zu 90%
wenn man BTOP auf seinem Desktop aufruft
ist es doch, weil man denkt,
irgendwas läuft im Hintergrund und hängt.
Und dann macht man BTOP auf.
Und wenn ich hier oben sehe, dass ein CPU-Core
komplett auf 100% Anschlag hängt
dann weiß ich gleich, ok, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Welche vor allem bei Workstation?
Also hier oben
hab ich direkt in der DICE
den Überblick, was abgeht.
Meine Load, CPU-Auslastung pro Core
und CPU insgesamt
Disk, RAM
Das ist übrigens RAM
nicht CPU, ich erzähl Blödsinn.
RAM, Disk
Datum und eine Uhr
ein Countdown-Timer
falls man mal einen braucht.
Jo
Und ansonsten
wenn du servermäßig was bauen willst
würd ich mich erstmal mit
den gängigen Sachen vertraut machen
ich würd mir mal eine Debian installieren
kannst du auch in der VM machen
dort SSH beispielsweise so einrichten
mit einem Client, dass du dich per Keys
authentifizieren kannst
bevor du irgendwelche großen Projekte machst
guck dir erstmal die Basics an
da kommst du dann besser mit klar
und wenn du dann irgendwann mal soweit bist
dann ist dir hoffentlich ein ordentliches Projekt
eingefallen, irgendwas was du auch brauchst
von bisschen Heimautomatisierung
zu irgendwelchen Programmierprojekten
irgendwelche Webseiten hosten
Zertifikate ausstellen
was auch immer, gibt's halt alle möglichen Sachen
die Basics machen wir erstmal
korrekt
so sieht's aus, Hersteller sagen prinzipiell
immer die Wahrheit
Prime-Subscriber übrigens auch
To-Do-App
ja Moment, es geht ja nicht um Programmierprojekte
sondern um Linux-Einsteigerprojekte
eine To-Do-App
eine Debian-To-Do-App
was auch immer
ein Kubernetes-Cluster auf, beste Idee zum Einstieg
erstmal ein Kubernetes-Cluster
weil Kubernetes selbst zu hosten
auch so eine gute Idee ist
kann ich dir auch empfehlen
vor allem bei Workstation ist für mich die beste
Virtualisierungslösung die es gibt
hier für Windows
und du kannst dir einen billigen Key besorgen
ich verrate jetzt nicht wie
also bei Keyshops kannst du dir welchen kaufen
aber insgesamt findest du billige Keys
wobei ich wenige Kram gekauft hab
ja
so mach ich das auch
Video-Kram, Streaming über Windows
und Progress-Netzwerk und Bastel-Zeug
unter Linux
und das ohne Dual-Boot, weil ich persönlich kein Dual-Boot mag
wie heißt
Alter gucken wir jetzt doch grad mal
wie hieß der
wie hieß der Channel der auf
mein Linux
reaktet hat
ok
lass doch mal gucken ob der irgendwelche anderen Videos hat
wo wir mal drauf reakten können
wo ist denn das Video
hier
Linux-Youtuber reagiert
hat der irgendwas
meine 5 Tipps für Linux-Einsteiger
das hätte ich auch gern gehabt
ok da könnten wir vielleicht drauf
reakten
Wochenrückblick
Debian
10 Gründe
warum du nicht Linux nutzen solltest
ok das erinnert mich so ein bisschen
ja
lass mal kurz durchgucken
was sind die 10 Gründe
Benutzerfreundliche Spezialtreiber
Softwareinkompatibilität
Gaming unter Linux
Gewöhnungsbedarf
Zerstrittenheit und Umgangvielfalt
von Linux in Oberflächen
Verbreitung
äh ja gut
vieles davon hab ich ja auch gesagt
Snap
China-Chinesen
Linux
Linux Mint vs Debian
Debian auf dem Server
easy fertig aus
Du benutzt gerade Linux um deinen Stream zu schauen
ja beste
Fuzzy Finder
benutze ich auch aber recht wenig
also ich hab mir zum Beispiel
was mit FZF
Fuzzy Finder gebaut
und zwar für die Arbeit
ich liste mir mit G-Cloud CLI
alle
VMs in der Google Cloud auf
und pipe das dann nach FZF
dann kann ich dann drinnen suchen und selekten
und dann kann ich mich per SSH drauf verbinden
Hat das gestern mit den Bosch Thermostaten geklappt?
ja
aber nicht alles
und ich hab es auch noch nicht mit
ZigBee to MQTT probiert
womit es wohl besser funktionieren soll
und auch Firmware-Updates unterstützt
also das Einbinden hat sofort geklappt
das Einstellen von
nach nem Reboot vom Zertifikat
nachdem ich es an die Heizung montiert hab
hat auch das Einstellen von Temperatur
der Motor hat auch gesteuert
was nicht ging und was für mich so komplett
pipega ist
man konnte es nicht ausschalten
was enorm wichtig ist
weil wenn du das nicht ausschalten kannst
dann braucht es einfach viel zu viel Strom
wenn du das ausschalten kannst den ganzen Sommer über
dann brauchst du quasi fast ein halbes Jahr
sagen wir jetzt mal aufgerundet
in Deutschland vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
brauchst du fast ein halbes Jahr
kaum Energie für die Thermostate
und deswegen halten die Dinger auch 1,5-2 Jahre
und selbst wenn du es nur runterdrehst
auf 5 Grad oder so
es sackt halt
es ist halt doof dass du es nicht ausschalten kannst
du kannst es ausschalten
es gibt eine Heizpause die man einschalten kann
aber man kriegt es irgendwie nicht richtig eingeschaltet
am Thermostat selber
weil die Bedienung von dem Thermostat mit den Knöpfen
hyper pipega ist
und man kann
es halt nicht über die offizielle App machen
weil ich die offizielle App nicht benutzen kann
mal gucken wie das mit ZigP2MQTT ist
reicht doch im Mittag
ist Btop im Browser
also wenn du einen Zugriff per Browser brauchst
du kannst
irgendeinen Web-SSH machen
wenn es unbedingt sein muss
Web-SSH und dann
auf die Kiste drauf
aber warum muss es denn unbedingt im Browser sein
das würde mich jetzt interessieren
warum muss es unbedingt vom Browser
Web-Zugriff mit
irgendeinem Kommandozeilentool sein
ich meine wie gesagt kannst du auch
ja über Web machen
also mittlerweile
Web-Shell-Geschichten
kannst ja alles benutzen
würde ich auf einem
produktiven Server nicht unbedingt
drauf haben wollen
was meinst du mit Poggers programmieren
das ist
ja wir haben schon für alles ein bisschen bescheuerte Wörter
Poggers ist für mich Programmieren
das ist das Gegenstück zu Poggers
Poggers
ist ein Twitch-Emote
Poggers Programmieren quasi
Leute ich muss mal wieder was sagen
wisst ihr was mich übelst aufregt
deswegen habe ich das jetzt auch versucht
hier nicht so zu antworten
hätte auf diese Frage
die typische Foren-Antwort gewesen
oh warum willst du denn sowas machen
mach das doch lieber anders
solche Antworten regen mich immer auf
deswegen habe ich gesagt vielleicht kannst du ja
ein Web-Terminal installieren
aber mich würde trotzdem interessieren warum
das unbedingt per Web-Zugriff sein muss
vielleicht bist ja noch da
kannst ja mal im Chat geschrieben
ja
also eine Sache die mich immer übelst aufregt
und das hatte ich letzte Woche auf der Arbeit und zwar
wir verwenden auf der Arbeit
natürlich
kein Let's Encrypt
Let's Encrypt wäre viel zu einfach
zum Zertifikate ausstellen
wir benutzen irgendeinen
Zertifikats-Service
von irgendeinem Anbieter
der aber glücklicherweise
sich auch über Acme
spricht man das überhaupt so aus
automatisieren lässt
also du kannst Cert-Manager und sowas benutzen
aber du brauchst irgendwie ein Custom-Plugin
sodass das funktioniert
na gut
zumindest
wollte ich das letzte Woche machen mal
habe ich Kubernetes Cluster, Cert-Manager installiert
habe das versucht einzurichten
und da ist mir aufgefallen
bevor ich das jetzt einrichte
und 50 mal meinen Helmchart-Uninstaller installiere
frag doch mal
was das für Limits hat
weil Chat, habt ihr euch schon mal ausgesperrt
bei Let's Encrypt
hat schon mal jemand
die Ehre gehabt sich auszusperren
bei Let's Encrypt
weil er entweder nicht Staging benutzt hat
oder zu oft die gleichen Einträge abgefragt hat
eine Woche warten
ja genau
es gibt übrigens ein Trick
bei Let's Encrypt
wie man das etwas mehrmals
hat wahrscheinlich jeder gerade am Anfang schon mal auf die Reihe gekriegt
also
es gibt ein Trick
bei Let's Encrypt
das versuche ich euch mal kurz zu erklären
also Let's Encrypt hat ja
hat ja mehrere Limits
insgesamt Limits
Limits pro Request
und sowas
Zertifikate pro registrierte Domain
bis zu 100 Namen per Zertifikat
und sowas in der Richtung
wenn ihr in das allgemeine Limit lauft
dann habt ihr gelitten
aber was geht ist
ihr könnt also mal angenommen
ihr möchtet ein Zertifikat ausstellen
für
www.kapalul.com
oder sag mal ihr wollt ein Wildcard sogar ausstellen
ihr wollt sowas ausstellen
alles von unterhalb www.kapalul.com
und ihr habt das zu oft gemacht
und Let's Encrypt sagt euch
dann macht einfach folgendes
dann macht einen neuen Zertifikatrequest
und fragt zusätzlich im gleichen Zertifikatrequest
noch das Zertifikat dafür an
das funktioniert
also
bei Let's Encrypt zählt nicht
nur die Domain
sondern es zählt der
SN
also der Name
es zählen alle
Domains
Subjects
also es zählt
die komplette Kombination aus
den ganzen Namen im Zertifikat
also sprich wenn ihr eigentlich
nur das hier haben wollt
und Let's Encrypt hat euch gesperrt
dann fragt einfach noch im gleichen Request
etwas anderes an für die Domain
dann zählt das als neuer Request
weil es eben nicht exakt die gleiche
Sache ist
das globale Insgesamtlimit
könnt ihr damit nicht umgehen
aber für bestimmte Subdomains könnt ihr es damit umgehen
wenn ihr mal in der misslichen Lage seid
und euch ausgesperrt habt
bei Let's Encrypt
das funktioniert umgedreht
übrigens genauso
wenn ihr www angefragt habt
dann könnt ihr zusätzlich noch einfach
www2 oder so anfragen
und dann geht das auch wieder
aber wie gesagt
nicht das globale Limit
nur das für die einzelnen
Einträge kann man
wenn man die ändert
was haben wir denn da für Limits
bevor ich jetzt 50 mal das aninstalle
und installiere und dann haben wir eben ein Limit
und wisst ihr was die Antwort war
anstatt zu sagen oh ich weiß nicht
ich muss mal gucken
haben dann 2 Leute sinnlos
darüber diskutiert warum man das
nicht irgendwie anders machen kann
und das fuckt mich immer unglaublich ab
wisst ihr ich frag ganz konkret
wie ist denn das Limit
für Zertifikatsanfragen
haben die irgendwie ein Limit
dass man sich mal irgendwie
vertippt oder zu viel aninstalliert
ja das erste was kam so nach dem Motto
ja kannst du nicht
in deinem Helmchart einfach TLS
erstmal disablen und es ausprobieren
und erst dann wenn es wieder akut wird
TLS enablen
doch doch das kann ich schon machen
aber ich will einfach nur die Limits wissen
für den Fall der Fälle
man weiß ja nie
und gerade wenn es kaputt ist
dass man auch dran denkt
boah hat mich das abgefuckt
das war das erste mal das mich so richtig aufgeregt hat auf der Arbeit
die Leute wussten es nicht
die wollten einfach nicht sagen sie wussten es nicht
glücklicherweise
habe ich danach jemand angeschrieben
ähm
mit
mit der gleichen Frage
wie ist das
mit Limits
und er hat tatsächlich gesagt
weiß er nicht aber er vermutet
die Limits sind sehr hoch
und ich soll mir erstmal keine Gedanken machen
sollte ich irgendwie
an Limits stroßen
ich soll auch gar nicht versuchen
ich soll es auch gar nicht versuchen zu umschiffen
ich soll ruhig mal richtig richtig Gas geben
und gucken ob ich da irgendwas raus finde
aber laut Google gibt es da
keine Limits
es gibt wohl irgendwie insgesamt
10.000 Stück oder so
was kein Problem ist
und das war wenigstens eine hilfreiche Antwort
aber die anderen
die haben so sinnlos diskutiert
ja muss man das denn überhaupt machen
ich wollte einfach nur die Limits wissen
ist das jetzt irgendwie
ganz furchtbar ketzerische Frage gewesen
dass man es nicht kaputt machen will
nee das ist immer ätzend
ja gestern meinte der Chat ja
ich soll es mal ausprobieren
das ist Müll
das ist richtig Müll
ich mag das überhaupt nicht
Windows in AVM und dann Grafikkarte durchreichen
da hast du viel mehr Probleme im Endeffekt
grafische Ausgabe auf dein Hauptmonitor
wenn du die Grafikkarte durchreichst
wie kriegst du USB und Tastaturgeräte
in deine VM um zu spielen
und das alles möglichst lagfrei
es ist
es ist nicht schön ganz ehrlich
die beste Kombination
also ich gebe dir recht das Dualboot stinkt
aber Grafikkarte durchreichen
ist auch Müll
das aus meiner Sicht Beste ist
Windows und Dehnung in der VM
weil man in der VM alles machen kann was man will
und außer vielleicht
so Sachen wie Video Decoding Video Encoding
weil eben keine Grafikkarten Decoder
und Encoder am Start sind
und ansonsten
vollkommen egal
kannst du alles mitmachen
ja das ist gut wenn man es braucht
aber es ist nicht jetzt
sinnvoll für die meisten Anwendungsfälle
wenn man GPU passt
oder generell PCIe passt
muss man ja sagen braucht es es sinnvoll
hab ich auch schon gemacht
mit einer 10GB Netzwerkkarte
oder mit einem kompletten
mit einem kompletten
SAS Controller
hab ich auch schon gemacht
passt
funktioniert
aber ich mag GPU passt
nicht und das dann als
Alternative für Windows
das mag in manchen Fällen
für manche Leute funktionieren
aber so pauschal
zum Beispiel wie kriegst du die
Ausgabe von der Grafikkarte auf den Monitor
auf den gleichen Monitor
wie dein Linux kriegst du schon mal net
und einfach das dann im Fenster anzeigen lassen
wie hier unter Linux ist dann auch net
weil die Grafikkarte ist durchgereicht
das heißt die Grafikkarte gibt auch die Sachen nur
aus an einem HDMI Ausgang oder so
da brauchst du einen zweiten Monitor
schaltest entweder den Monitor um hast zwei Inputs am Monitor
du nimmst sowas wie Looking Glass
dann hast du immer einen 1 Frame Delay
was nicht wild ist bei 240 FPS
aber trotzdem
es ist alles nicht so schön
wie man das gerne hätte
ja problematisch
nur wenn du dich aussperrst beim Wildcard Zertifikate ausstellen
wie hast du eigentlich deine privaten Daten
wie hast du eigentlich deine privaten Daten organisiert
Rechnung, Schriftverkehr
liegen die alle auf der Windows Kiste
oder auf einem Server
ganz einfach das meiste Zeug krieg ich per Papier
immer noch auch vom Finanzamt
und ich hab einfach im Schrank
obere
oberes Abteil im Schrank
da hab ich ein paar Kisten
und da schmeiß ich einfach die Sachen rein
fertig
das wars
was ich habe ist für Rechnung
und sowas was steuerrelevant ist
dass ich das auch an meinen Steuerberater schicken kann
da hab ich in Google Drive
also in der Google Cloud
hab ich einen Drive
was ich freigegeben hab für den Steuerberater
und da schieb ich einfach alles rein
was der braucht
Rechnung die ich schreibe
Rechnung die ich bekomme
irgendwelche Auszahlungsbelege
da gibt es einen Ordner für Steuern
der hat im Endeffekt
noch zwei Unterordner
Eingaben, Ausgaben
und dann so grob ein bisschen strukturiert
Twitch, Youtube
Sponsoring und solche Geschichten
aber im Großen und Ganzen
was relevant ist für Steuer auf Google Drive
und den Rest
wenn ich das in Papierform krieg
hau ich einfach bei mir in den Schrank
und fertig aus
ja und ich hab ganz viele Sachen
in meinem IMAP Postfach
was man so per Mail kriegt
dafür gibt es ja IMAP
dass du dich nicht selbst kümmern musst
wobei die super
die richtig wichtigen Sachen hab ich hier
so Einkommenssteuer erkläre
und die Lohnsteuerbescheinigung
das hab ich alle so im Zettel hier im Schrank
das kriegt man ja auch noch
analog
das ist richtig
wenn du sowas machen willst dann ist das sinnvoll
aber es ging ja die ganze Zeit um Spielen in der VM
wenn man solche Sachen machen möchte
wie Machine Learning
ja dann ist GPU Passthrough sinnvoll
wobei Machine Learning
machst du ja nicht wirklich in der VM
sondern das machst du ja wahrscheinlich
dann auf deinem Host
da musst du dann auch nix passthrouhen
und wenn doch dann schon ja
dann macht das Sinn
also wenn du sowas wie Proxmox hast
und willst dort eine VM starten
für Machine Learning gedöhnt
und Models lernen
ja dann schon
aber darauf spielt man ja dann auch nicht
das macht dann durchaus Sinn
da brauchst du aber von der Grafikkarte
auch die grafische Ausgabe nicht
sondern eigentlich nur die Rechenleistung
natürlich ist es möglich
auf dem selben Videoausgleich
wenn du eine Grafikkarte durchreichst
dann hat die nichts mehr
mit deinem Hostbetriebssystem zu tun
das heißt die Bilder kommen erst mal raus
aus dem HDMI Ausgang
dann kannst du nur noch so Sachen wie Looking Glass
oder solche Dinger verwenden
die versuchen den Frame Buffer
zu kopieren
rüber auf dein Hostbetriebssystem
uns dann anzuzeigen
dann hast du aber immer automatisch 1-2 Frame Delays
was bei 240 FPS nicht schlimm ist
aber ok
was soll es für andere Möglichkeiten
rein logisch gesehen
wie willst du es anders machen
da kann es zigtausend Tutorials geben
sag mal wie willst du es anders machen
mir fällt jetzt
ich will nicht sagen dass es nichts gibt
aber mir fällt keine andere Möglichkeit ein
wie willst du von einer durchgereichten Grafikkarte
das Bild
auf hier
sagen wir mal hier das hier wäre jetzt meine VM
und ich will jetzt hier die Grafikausgabe mir angucken
von der VM
wie soll das funktionieren
entweder schließt du den Monitor an
schließt du das HDMI Kabel am gleichen Monitor an
und schaltest den Monitor um
dass man den Treiber vom Hostband an den Guest weitergibt
ja gut
ja das ist schön
aber dann kannst du ja nicht gleichzeitig
dein Host, die VM und dein Host benutzen
das ist ja
das ist genau das gleiche
wie du nimmst 2 HDMI Kabel
und schließt 2 mal per Monitor an
und schaltet es dann irgendwie um
das ist halt
das ist halt weit davon entfernt
den Komfort zu haben
von ich hab hier nun meine VM
auf dem zweiten Desktop und kann so dazwischen umschalten
beziehungsweise kann auch sagen
hier guck mal ich kopiere einfach mal schnell ein paar Dinge rüber
und so
ups
das war jetzt ne blöde Idee
ich will nicht mein Heimatverzeichnis in die VM kopieren
ups
das war jetzt keine so gute Idee
ich glaube ich muss
ok close program
du hast sogar der Explorer abgeschissen
bei
wenn der Guest aber runterfährt dann bist du wieder im Host
ja ok
das kann ich mir vorstellen
aber das ist ja nicht gleichzeitig benutzen
da sieht man man braucht für alles
und das ist das warum ich das nicht mag
man muss für die einfachsten Sachen
im Vergleich zu der VM Lösung
alles mit irgendwelchen Workarounds bauen
die dann noch nicht mal ansatzweise so gut funktionieren wie das hier
natürlich hat man dann halt auch die GPU Power in der VM
aber wozu brauche ich die GPU Power in der VM
wenn ich einfach das Setup machen kann
was den vollen Komfort bietet
die volle GPU Power dort hat wo ich es brauche
und mehr oder weniger zu 99%
Linux so benutzen kann
mit allem was es bietet und wofür es gut ist
also deswegen
ich persönlich bin der Meinung
das beste Setup und das produktivste Setup
ist immer noch Windows als Host
und ne ordentliche VM
auch mit ordentlichen Ressourcen
auf dem zweiten Desktop
machen kann es jeder wie er will
ich für meinen Teil finde das am besten
was habt ihr so auf eurem Heimserver laufen
aktuell noch Unraid
und es bleibt es wahrscheinlich auch erstmal
aber wirklich glücklich bin ich mit
keinen der Lösungen
vielleicht mache ich mir einfach wieder
einen Debian drauf wie früher
welche VM Software ich benutze VM
bei Workstation
Debian 12.1 ist raus
ok das ging aber schnell für
Debian Verhältnisse oder
Debian 12.1 erst vor einem Monat raus
oder vor 2 Wochen
oder so
ja das ist ne gute Variante
das kannst du machen
die Grafikkarte von der CPU
für Host und
die GPU in die VM
da hast du aber immer noch das Problem
du musst die grafischen Ausgaben irgendwie am Monitor
irgendwie zum Monitor hinbringen
das heißt du kannst zum Beispiel 2 Kabel
an 2 Monitore oder 2 Kabel an gleichem Monitor
und dann umschalten am Monitor
durchaus mit verdrehbarem Aufwand
aber halt
trotzdem nicht ganz so komfortabel wie einfach den Desktop switchen
dafür hast du
volle Grafikpower
dann ist halt die Frage wie bekommst du zum Beispiel
deine Maus und Tastatur ordentlich rein
ahja gut auch mit irgendwelchen Workarounds
ja
89 Bugfixes
wenn man sich mal überlegt wie viel Software in Debian
drin ist denn 89 Bugfixes
ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so viel
hält sich in Grenzen
mal kurz gucken die aktuellen
ShitHub Trends
AI oh ne es geht wieder los Leute
AI
ich weiß nicht was es sein soll ehrlich gesagt
Fast and Memory
Efficient Exact Attention
Flash
hä was soll das
was soll das sein
ah ja ah GPT
ok AI
hätte man auch hier reinschreiben können
AI
Webapplications mit Rust
pass mal auf lass mal gucken wie eklig das aussieht
du hast schon
Onlyfansbots
angetextet
man muss sich jetzt überlegen
ich
ich geb euch jetzt mal einen Ratschlag
bei der Auswahl von Frameworks
beziehungsweise eigentlich nicht bei der Auswahl von Frameworks
beim Lesen
von GitHub Readmes und zwar
ihr müsst immer von folgendem Fall ausgehen
die Sachen
die euch in Readmes gezeigt werden
das sind
also davon solltet ihr ausgehen
das ist der bestmögliche
Fall bestmöglich
dargestellt
das heißt wenn der schon
eklig aussieht
könnt ihr von ausgehen in der praktischen Anwendung
ist es noch ekliger
das hier geht vollkommen klar von der Optik
noch
aber man sieht schon
man sieht schon so ein bisschen die Ekligkeiten
der Rust-Syntaxe an manchen Stellen
warum benutzt du freiwillig Windows 11
ne was ist die Alternative
Windows 10 oder
Windows XP
was soll die Alternative sein
ne ne ne
achso ja warum
warum benutzt du nicht Mint oder so
warum ich
Windows 11 benutze ist ganz einfach
weil meine CPU
nur gescheit supportet wird unter Windows 11
das ist der Grund
da sag ich gleich was zu
haben wir uns schon
angeguckt AI
AI
Schieder Chinesen AI
ich hab keine Ahnung was das sein soll Leute
mhm mhm mhm mhm
naja alles klar
mhm mhm mhm
ok Google
Google Translate
nicht auf Russisch Alter
Moment wie konnte man nochmal
Webseiten Translaten
ging das nicht hier oben irgendwie drüber
mh es gab doch
Translate
Websites genau
äh
Foren Sprache erkennen
nein nein nein Deutsch noch Englisch
ok China Chinesen Kram
Wir sind wir sehen
Dehydrated Version of Tianya
Got Was zum
Real Estate
Regulation
Was haben die Chinesen hier auf Github gehostet
Was ist das
Got Post Chat Haus Price
What
Ist das
auto wie kauf ich mir in China ein Haus oder
ja das ist wirklich
wie das ist ein Guide wie kauf ich mir
in China ein Haus
Haus Slaves?
Alter, was ist mit den Chinesen los?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was das für eine...
um was es geht.
Wahrscheinlich ist es nicht,
nachdem es sich anhört.
Aber es trendet auf jeden Fall schon mal mit 16.000 GitHub-Sternen.
AI, LogSec, okay.
NetData, Tabby.
AI.
Naja, so spannend ist es jetzt nicht, was die Woche trendet.
80% wieder AI.
Schauen wir nochmal kurz, was in der .NET-Welt so trendet.
Die Woche.
To-Do-App.
Da siehst du, in der .NET-Welt war nichts los,
wenn eine To-Do-App trendet auf GitHub.
Das ist der ASP.NET-Erfinder, oder?
Hier.
Ja.
Glaub ich, guck hier.
Äh, ASP.NET-Team.
Oder zumindest einer Miterfinder von ASP.NET-Core.
Okay, das sind wahrscheinlich quasi so halboffizielle Samples.
Deswegen hat das so viele Sterne.
Äh, WebRP.
Sharp WX-Dump.
Okay, China-Chinesen-Zeug, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Machine Learning.
Text Editor for China-Chinesen Chat App.
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Kerberos.
Aha.
Okay, Power Tools, äh, Power Toys.
Lean Algorithmic Trade Engine.
Bestimmt AI-Zeug.
Material Design für WPF.
Ja, weil WPF outdated, overrated, shebaited.
Alter hässlicher Kram ist.
Plotting Library.
Ha, Maui.
MonkaS.
Terminal UI.
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Ich fand's von der Idee her ganz cool, aber es hat mich zu sehr an N-Curses erinnert.
Mixed Reality.
Unity-Zeug.
Ein Game.
Was ich sehr cool finde, dass ein Game trendet.
Auch ein Spiel, was gar nicht übel aussah.
Also pixelgrafikmäßig.
Muss man was, muss man was trinken.
Kratzt im Hals.
So, dann haben wir N-Audio.
Tatsächlich, das hab ich schon benutzt, das ist eine nice Audio Library.
Damit haben wir mal eine China-Chinesen-Kamera verbunden mit einer Windows-Forms-App, wo
man Two-Way-Audio mitmachen konnte.
Haben wir in irgendeinem Stream gemacht, ich erinnere mich noch.
Two-Way-Audio von so einer China-Chinesen-Kamera zu einer Windows-App.
Nicht, weil ich's irgendwie groß verwenden wollte, sondern weil ich wissen wollte, wie
es geht.
Escape from Tarkov.
Offline-Koop.
Okay.
PowerShell.
WireHead.
Ah, das ist, da haben wir doch letztens das Video zugeguckt.
Cool, dass das trendet.
Da haben wir letztens das Video noch zugeguckt.
Das ist der Typ, der quasi die Wire-Logik in Terraria neu gebaut hat, damit er einen
Computer in Terraria bauen konnte.
Ja, das trendet auch.
Terraria-Mods.
View-Face-Score.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Ah, Face-Recognition.
Ja, das ist klar.
Da stehen die Chinesen drauf.
Automatische Kamera-Footage-Auswertung und Image-Bilder-Gesichtserkennung.
Typisches China-Chinesen-Thema.
Weil man sagen muss, da ist es vielleicht besonders verbreitet, aber für alle anderen
ist es natürlich auch praktisch.
Ja, das ist klar.
Da stehen die Chinesen drauf.
Automatische Kamera-Footage-Auswertung und Image-Bilder-Gesichtserkennung.
Typisches China-Chinesen-Thema.
Wo ist die Frage mit dem...
Hier.
Wie steht dein Arbeitgeber zu deiner Nebentätigkeit?
Also, was der dazu denkt, weiß ich nicht.
Er weiß es auf jeden Fall.
Er wusste es schon, bevor ich mich dort beworben habe.
Weil es stand ja sogar in meiner Bewerbung drinnen.
Also bei mir können sie sich echt nicht beschweren, wir wussten davon nichts.
Es stand in meiner Bewerbung drinnen und wir haben im Vorstellungsgespräch sogar noch
drüber gesprochen.
Und wir haben uns sogar einen GitHub-Repo angeguckt mit einem Projekt drinnen, wo wir
im Stream dran teilweise schon mitentwickelt haben.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, was sie davon denken, aber sie scheinen ja nichts
dagegen gehabt zu haben.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass das deine Karriere behindern könnte?
Muss man sich für einen Nebentäter immer vom Arbeitgeber...
Das stimmt.
Wobei, die Sache die ist, sie können so ohne weiteres nichts dagegen sagen und ich glaube,
es ist noch komplizierter, wenn du die Nebentätigkeit schon machst, bevor du dort angefangen hast
und wenn es halt auch gar nichts damit zu tun hat.
Ja.
Muss man.
Man muss es immer dort bekannt geben.
Aber bei mir können sie sich aber wirklich nicht beschweren, dass sie es nicht gewusst
haben.
Die wussten das schon, bevor ich in der Bewerbung sogar selbst stand, schon drinnen.
Also, wenn da einer sagt so nach dem Motto, ach Max, hättest du mal früher was gesagt.
Sag ich, ich hab so früh wie irgendwie mögliches davon was gesagt.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass du deine Karriere behindern könnte?
Also, die Frage muss man anders stellen.
Die muss man doppelt stellen.
Also, die Frage muss ich auf zwei Arten interpretieren.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass deine Karriere behindert werden könnte?
Nein, hab ich nicht, weil ich hab nicht vor, Karriere zu machen.
Wenn du fragen würdest, hast du das Gefühl, dass das deine, falls ich es machen wollte,
möchte, Karriere behindern könnte, dann müsste ich sagen, ja, vielleicht.
Das hab ich übrigens auch letztens, wo wir gerade dabei sind, genau das Thema hab ich
doch sogar angesprochen.
Weiß ich, hast du das Video hier geguckt?
Da rede ich ja unter anderem genau über sowas.
Also, ja, theoretisch, wenn ich Karriere machen wollen würde, könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass das ab einer gewissen Stufe problematisch wäre, allerdings weniger die Nebentätigkeit
selbst, sondern, dass ich nur vier Tage die Woche arbeite, was von wegen der Nebentätigkeit
kommt.
Ja, vielleicht, aber für mich, nö.
Ich hab auch, ihr wisst ja, ich hab auch keine Ambitionen, was irgendwie Karriere machen
angeht.
Muss man ja auch nicht, weil man verdient, wenn man Techniker ist, beziehungsweise, nenn
das mal IT-Spezialist, Experte-Typ halt, der was kann, was halbwegs gefragt ist, verdient
man genug Kohle, ohne dass man irgendwie den krassen Karriere-Client machen muss, also
ohne dass ich jetzt sagen würde, oh, ich will noch irgendwie mal ein bisschen Projektmanagement
machen oder sowas.
Geh mal bloß fort.
Ich glaube, das ist das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, noch nebenbei Projektmanagement
mitmachen zu wollen.
Projektmanagement ist, es gibt so zwei Sachen, da kriegst du immer Anschiss, das ist, wenn
du Projektmanager bist, kriegst du immer Anschiss von den Leuten, die mitarbeiten im Projekt
und von den Leuten, die das Projekt quasi ownen und Budgetplanung machen und wenn du
Teamleiter bist, kriegst du immer Anschiss von deinem Team und den Leuten um drüber.
Das sind zwei Positionen, die würde ich nie im Leben machen wollen.
Natürlich, es könnte auch noch sein, irgendwie muss ich noch was trinken, so, und dann hast
du natürlich noch die Möglichkeit, hey, wenn du in deinem, in deiner Nebentätigkeit, beispielsweise
ich auf YouTube oder hier im Stream, wenn ich dort Sachen machen würde, die irgendwie
entgegen dem sind, was meinem Arbeitgeber gefällt, ja, also, also erstens, erstens,
bei mir ist das eh kein Problem, weil niemand weiß, wo ich arbeite, das heißt, da kann
der Arbeitgeber auch nicht argumentieren, Max, du sagst in deinem Stream, was, was gegen
die Firmenwerte wäre oder irgendwie sowas, weil solange es keiner zusammenbringt, kann
man sich da auch nicht beschweren, das weiß vielleicht der, aber da kann kein, das mögen
vielleicht dort ein paar Leute herstellen können diesen Zusammenhang, aber es kann
niemand den Zusammenhang sonst herstellen, weil es weiß schlicht und ergreifend keiner
und da kann man auch nicht argumentieren, ah, das würde uns irgendwie schaden.
Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise sagen würde, hier, ich arbeite bei einer deutschen Bank,
was, was ich nicht mache, ja, sag nur, und ich würde jetzt öffentlich sagen, ah, habt
ihr schon die letzte Kampagne gesehen, die die deutsche Bank macht mit, keine Ahnung,
Jan Ullrich, ich hab keinen Schimmer, ob die sowas machen und alter, der Typ, der sackt
übelst und die bescheißen nur die Leute und so, also mal angenommen, wenn ich mich
dann so positionieren würde, würde gegen meinen Arbeitgeber, da könnten die sicherlich
was dagegen sagen, wobei ich Jan Ullrich übelst, also, naja, ich hab halt früher viel Radsport
geguckt, auch zu den Zeiten so 1997, so war das ja mega Hype, ich find ja Jan Ullrich
eigentlich ganz nice, ähm, in den letzten Jahren, naja, sagen wir mal so, vielleicht
nicht unbedingt das Vorbild gewesen, aber es war ja nur ein Beispiel. So, das ist sicherlich
was von Arbeitgeber, was dagegen sagen könnte, aber bei mir, und, bei mir, bei mir gibt's
das Problem nicht, weil das weiß halt keiner, wo ich arbeite, außer ein paar Leute dort,
was aber nicht wild ist, weil niemand argumentieren könnte, ja, aber, wenn du öffentlich dann
was dazu sagst, dann bringen das die Leute ja zusammen und das schadet uns, das schadet
halt nix, weil's keiner weiß. Ich merk übrigens, dass ich mega alt bin, ich hab letztens nachgeguckt,
Jan Ullrich ist, glaub ich, 48 oder so mittlerweile, 49, Alter, da merk ich, dass ich übelst alt
bin, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, da hab ich 1997 und so, hab ich beim Opa Tour
de France geguckt, Jan Ullrich, alle voll gehypt, da war ich, da war ich klein noch,
da war ich so ein kleiner Hüpfer, 1997 war ich 13, 13, Jan Ullrich war da, keine Ahnung,
23 oder so, krass, oder? Das richtig, da merkt man mal, wie richtig Ultra-Boomer man mittlerweile
ist, heftig, ja, so, so viel, so viel dazu. Was für einen Kühler hast du? Ganz einfach,
pass mal auf, macht mal Chat, Chat, Ausrufezeichen, äh, das ist Ausrufezeichen PC, ja, Ausrufezeichen
PC ist es, ja, da kommt ihr auf die Zusammenstellung von meinem aktuellen Rechner und ich habe
als Lüfter einen Arctic Liquid Freezer Wasserkühler, RGB natürlich, was sonst? Das ist mein Lüfter
quasi. Erste Mal, dass ich eine Wasserkühlung hab und ich muss sagen, bis jetzt, mega nice,
überhaupt keine Probleme, alles gut, alles pog, ja, wurde umbenannt, schon vor einer Weile. Wie
sieht es denn eigentlich aus mit KI und IT, wie jetzt, wie soll es da aussehen? Das ist ein immer
gefragteres Feld und das ist ein Trend, der geht, der wird vielleicht für viele noch nicht so
relevant sein, aber der geht auf jeden Fall an keinem ernstzunehmenden IT-Führungskreis vorbei,
sich da nicht ein bisschen Gedanken drüber zu machen, was das bedeuten könnte für das,
für das eigene Unternehmen. An vielen geht es noch ein bisschen vorbei, aber ich glaube,
auf dem Radar haben es viele. Gibt es eigentlich Source Code in Kyrillisch wahrscheinlich,
die Franzosen, wollte ich gerade sagen, die Franzosen schreiben auch gerne französische
Variablen an, wobei, ganz ehrlich, ich sehe das ja teilweise sogar für Leute, die in der
Berufsschule oder teilweise sogar an der Uni noch, aber eher Berufsschule, irgendwelche
Übungsprogramme programmieren und das heißt dann wirklich, da gibt es dann wirklich Variablen,
die heißen Nummer oder Zähler und sowas. Da kriege ich immer Anfälle, wenn ich das sehe. Schreibt
den Kram halt in Englisch und fertig ist, da lernt man auch gleich, das ordentlich zu benennen alles.
Außerdem, die eigentliche Pfeiffert-Variante ist doch nicht, also, das ist, das ist Noob,
der Nächste schreibt Counter, der Advanstere schreibt C, CNT und der Pro schreibt einfach
nur noch C. Easy. Wird einfach immer weiter abgekürzt. Wobei ich ja persönlich das hier
nicht verkehrt finde, da weiß man wenigstens, was gemeint ist. Und irgendwann haben die Leute
gar keinen Bock mehr und benutzen nur noch Autocomplete, dann heißt alles nur noch I oder
N oder Z. Ich glaube, I, N und Z sind die Default-Autocomplete-Dinger, wenn du Nested-Schleifen
machst. Der hat Ärger vor... Ja gut, aber der hat ja auch öffentlich gesagt, der arbeitet bei
Facebook und hat sich dazu geäußert. Dann ist es so, dann ist ja direkt die Verbindung herstellbar.
Ist ja bei mir nicht. Habt ihr gestern auch Probleme? Nö. Für Mitbewerber bin ich auch
nicht tätig. Nö, bin ich nicht. Ich bin für mich tätig. Das Ding ist, ich würde nebenbei einfach
gerne eigene Projekte umsetzen im SaaS-Umfeld. Ich habe nur die Frage... Wieso? Wenn du eigene
Projekte machst, ist für den Arbeitgeber doch extremly POG, dann hast du Ahnung von was, was
du auf der Arbeit benutzen kannst. Wo ist das Problem, eigene Projekte umzusetzen? Das sehe
ich überhaupt kein Problem. Ich meine, man kann es nie ausschließen, dass es irgendwelche PPGA
Arbeitgeber, PPGA Chefs gibt. Aber ganz ehrlich, wo ist das? Da würde ich überhaupt kein Problem
dabei sehen. Da lernst du ja auch was, was dir im Job was bringen kann. Ohne, dass sie irgendwelche
Schulungen bezahlen müssten oder du Einarbeitung bräuchtest und erst mal ein paar Wochen nichts
machen kannst. Also das würde ich eher von Vorteil sehen, wenn Leute sowas machen möchten. Man weiß
nie, wie manche Arbeitgeber ticken, aber da sehe ich jetzt gar kein Problem. Solange gültig...
Gleich true, genau. Am besten noch in einer IF-Schleife. IF-Schleife ist eh einfach das
Beste. Wir sollten nur noch in IF-Schleifen programmieren. Sprechende Variablenamen ist
aber dann schon sinnvoll. Ja, Moment. Du brauchst sprechende Variablenamen ja nur,
wenn es einfacher zu lesen sein soll, also sprich einfacher zu debunken soll und debunken musst du
nur, wenn du was falsch gemacht hast. Wenn du instant immer perfekt funktionierenden,
hundertprozentig durchdachte Sachen programmierst, die einfach instant funktionieren, dann kannst du
schreiben, wie du willst. Dann brauchst du auch keine Doku und Tests. Einfach das Beste. Einfach
immer fehlerfrei programmieren und du hast überhaupt keine Probleme mehr. Du hast alle
Probleme gelöst, instant. Easy. Ja, sag ich doch. Einfach keine Fehler programmieren. So wie wir das
im Stream auch immer machen. Also bei mir im Stream ist es prinzipiell ja immer so. Sobald es
kompiliert, funktioniert es auch hundertprozentig. Hat man ja schon oft gesehen. Ja, siehste? Gut,
gut, dass ihr hier gewesen seid, dass ihr das gehört habt. Ist das etwa diese Fake-Webseite,
die uns sagen möchte, dass es keine IF-Schleifen gibt? Ah, ganzen Loops wieder alle keine Ahnung
haben sie. Richtig, genau. Deswegen, dass es keine Bugs gibt, sieht man auch einfach hier dran. Guck,
es ist offensichtlich, dass es keine Bugs gibt. Sonst hätte ich nicht so viele Tickets schon
schließen müssen. Es sind immerhin mehr Tickets closed als offen. Multiple Cars ist kein Bug.
Das ist eine Designentscheidung. Das ist eindeutig Anwendungsfehler. Absicht. Absicht,
ich will, dass die Leute sich nicht aussperren. Warum sollte man Charging vorher absicht? Neue
Home Assistant-Version liegt an Home Assistant, nicht an meinem Add-on. Post-Commands failing
mit 403, Anwenderfehler. Prinzipiell überhaupt kein Problem an der Software. Es wird echt mal
Zeit. Ich muss unbedingt das Ding überarbeiten, weil spätestens, wenn ich mein Home Assistant
mal upgrade, dann wird er wahrscheinlich auch kaputt gehen, weil die irgendwas geändert haben
an ihrem Add-on, Einlese-Zeug. Es wird Zeit für Fiat Champ Version 2. Wobei wir sind schon bei
Version 3 eigentlich. Also Version 4. Fiat Champ 4.0. Wobei ich das Ding nicht neu bauen werde,
aber ein bisschen erweitern. Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, wie man es am besten macht. Zum
Beispiel muss ich endlich einbauen, dass mehrere Fahrzeuge unterstützt werden, wenn man sie von
unterschiedlichen Herstellern hat. Aktuell kannst du mehrere Autos von Fiat haben, aber gerade bei
den Amis, die haben irgendeinen Dodge Truck und noch einen Fiat und das funktioniert mit dem
Add-on nicht und du kannst das Add-on auch nicht mehrfach installieren. Also du kriegst entweder
nur deinen Dodge Truck oder deinen Fiat rein, nicht beides. Wenn du zwei Dodge Trucks hättest,
dann würdest du sie reinkriegen oder zwei Fiats, aber nicht zwei unterschiedliche Hersteller. Ja,
das muss noch gefixt werden. Und auch das Handling mit den MQTT Messages und so,
das ist alles nicht schön gemacht und die Commands. Und auch die Fehlermeldung. Also ich
müsste echt mal das grundsätzlich überarbeiten mit dem, was ich gelernt habe aus der ersten
Version. Ja, so sieht es aus. Okay, Chat gehen. Viel geschwätzt. Lasst uns mal gucken. Können
wir uns noch irgendwelche YouTube Videos anschauen? Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
How Javascript ruined the web. I seriously almost just got hacked. Okay, das ist G-Bait. Das ist
garantiert G-Bait. So schnell wird dein Fahrrad... Das gucken wir jetzt mal als erstes. Ich glaube,
ich weiß nämlich, worum es geht, dass ein niederländischer Fahrradhersteller pleite ist
und das Fahrrad, um zum Einstellen von der Lichthelligkeit und sowas, eine App braucht. Und
die App wird bald nicht mehr funktionieren, weil die Server abgeschaltet werden. Also auf die Idee
muss man erst mal kommen, ein Fahrrad, ein E-Fahrrad, also ein Elektrofahrrad, so abhängig
zu machen von Cloud-Infrastruktur. Ja, genau. Ja, die meine ich. Für einen Rewrite müsstest du
gehyptere Sprachen... Nee, das macht nichts, dass ich wenige Leute finde, die mitentwickeln. Also
um gehypt zu sein, müsste ich es mal mindestens in Rust entwickeln, oder? Was wäre denn, Max,
noch eine Möglichkeit? Rewrite in Rust? Was ist denn sonst noch richtig gehypt aktuell? Mein
Python geht immer? Go vielleicht ein bisschen? Aber wenn ich es in Python mache, dann könnte
ich auch eine direkte Home Assistant Integration bauen. Und der Grund, warum ich es nicht in Python
mache, ist, weil ich nicht so der Python-Hacker-Man bin. Also Go, Go in Rust vielleicht, ja. JavaScript,
aber das ist alles so viel ekliger darin zu entwickeln, als in C-Sharp. Wobei Go geht noch
irgendwo. Hey, plus plus. Beste Idee, ja. Fängt ja schon damit an, dass die C++ Standard Library
keinen... Jetzt kommt ja der Hit. Die C++ Standard Library hat keinen Web-Client. Könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen? C++ Standard Lib hat keinen HTTP-Client. Nee, nee, wir fangen jetzt nicht davon an.
Wisst ihr, bei C++ diskutieren sie dann darüber, ja, wir können keinen Web-Client machen, weil wir
haben ja keinen Netzwerk-Stack und Netzwerk-Stack können wir nicht machen, weil wir auch Plattformen
unterstützen, die low-level sind. Andere Sprachen sagen einfach, okay, wir machen das trotzdem und
Sprachen, die es nicht supporten, dann gibt es halt eine not supported exception und fertig aus.
Könnte man in C++ auch machen, ja. Aber nein, man sagt lieber, nee, machen wir es gar nicht. So,
also gucken wir uns mal das an mit dem Fahrrad. Gucken, ob es da neue Erkenntnisse zu gibt.
Ich habe jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass das... They see me rolling. Das hätte jetzt einfach zu
gut gepasst. Guck mal hier, ich fahre hier auf meinem Rad. Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, der
Hersteller von meinem Fahrrad geht pleite. Ist ja egal, hat ja mit deinem Fahrrad nichts zu tun,
denkt ihr. Nee, so ist das nicht. Zumindest, wenn mein Fahrrad von VanMoof wäre. Ja, okay, war klar,
dass das kommt. Viele Funktionen bei diesen ziemlich beliebten Fahrrädern funktionieren
nur, wenn die VanMoof-Server laufen. Im schlimmsten Fall. Ich dachte, es heißt Move,
weil das ein Witz auf Movement ist, aber wahrscheinlich nicht. Kann man so ein Fahrrad
gar nicht mehr benutzen, wenn die Server ausgeschaltet sind. Nun hat VanMoof Insolvenz
angemeldet. Es weiß also niemand, wie das mit den Servern weitergeht. Man muss sich das echt mal
vorstellen, gell. Man braucht eine Cloud für sein Fahrrad. Alter, 2023, das ist einfach so pp-iger
in vielen Bereichen. Für sein scheiß Fahrrad eine Cloud-Anbindung. Es stimmt nicht so ganz.
Es stimmt nicht so ganz. Du kannst das Fahrrad noch benutzen, aber du kannst halt so Sachen wie
Lichthelligkeit und Entsperren und so nicht mehr benutzen. Und jetzt passt mal auf. Wisst ihr,
warum nicht? Viel besser. Es ist nicht so, als würde es offline nicht funktionieren. Nein,
nein. Die eigentliche Kommunikation zwischen Fahrrad und App funktioniert über Bluetooth,
aber die App braucht beim Start eine Verbindung zum Cloud-Server zum Entschlüsseln des Bluetooth-Keys.
Also es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Man könnte das ohne Probleme auf dem Smartphone speichern,
aber nein, will man nicht, weil man möchte ja Vendor-Login machen, um das Vendor-Login-Willens.
Übrigens, es gibt schon Abhilfe. Ich glaube, das wird da auch in dem Video zeigen. Es gibt
eine Konkurrenz-App, die das versucht nachzubauen und es gibt einen Key-Extractor auf GitHub,
der Fun-Move-Encryption-Key-Exporter. Da kann man sein Bike danach auch weiter benutzen. Großartig,
Punkt.io. Beste, beste Domain. Das Problem dabei ist nur, dass der 0815 weniger technikaffine
E-Bike-Benutzer, was es ja durchaus geben kann, schon ein wenig überfordert ist mit der Anleitung.
Allein schon, dass der Docker-Compose-Mann, der weiß noch nicht mal, was Docker überhaupt ist.
Aber gut, dass es das gibt. Okay, gucken wir uns das Video an.
Trotzdem, wenn die Server abgeschaltet werden, und wie kann das eigentlich sein,
dass man sich was kauft, also zum Beispiel ein Fahrrad, und dann darauf keinen Zugriff mehr hat,
nur weil der Hersteller pleite geht? Tja, willkommen in 2023. Ich find's auch kacke.
Skandal. Wir haben uns mal einen Fun-Move S1 und S3 besorgt und gucken,
was wir damit ohne Hersteller... Da muss er nicht selbst hosten,
er kann die Webseite benutzen. Okay, wenn es rein webbasiert ist. Du brauchst einen Windows-Rechner
mit Bluetooth wahrscheinlich, machst Web-Bluetooth, oder? Ja, dann ist es easy. Dann ist es tatsächlich
easy. Dann hab ich das falsch verstanden. Okay. Ja, dann ist es okay. Wenn das über die Website,
dann ist kein Problem. Das kriegt wahrscheinlich jeder hin. Das war bei BMW, glaube ich,
mit der Sitzheizung im Auto. Aber es ist doch mittlerweile gang und gäbe, dass die Technik
im Auto mehr hergibt, als eingeschaltet ist. Ich würde sagen, das ist eigentlich fast normal.
...Hersteller-Server überhaupt noch anfangen können. Bleibt dran.
Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors. Ja, ist ja gut, ey.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von 3CX. Wenn ich jetzt sagen würde... Also,
das hier ist echt mal wieder so eine Story, die vor zehn Jahren einfach komplett absurde
Science-Fiction gewesen wäre. Ja, das stimmt. Und die Story geht so. Besitzt man ein Elektro-Fahrrad
des Herstellers von MOV, kann das sein, dass man das Teil in Zukunft nicht mehr benutzen kann,
weil der Hersteller nämlich vor ein paar Tagen Insolvenz angemeldet hat. Und eigentlich ist
das ja erst mal total irrelevant für das mechanische Objekt Fahrrad. Das Rad bleibt
dann Rad. Denkt man, denkt man, ja. Egal, was mit dem Hersteller passiert. Aber von MOV-Rädern
funktionieren erst, wenn man sie über eine Smartphone-App aktiviert hat. Mit der App kann
man dann nicht nur Sachen wie die Automatik-Schaltung oder die Beleuchtung einstellen,
sondern damit öffnet man auch das Schloss bzw. schaltet die mechanische Wegfahrsperre aus. Das
war damals, als die ersten von MOV-Rädern rauskamen, ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Klingt
ja auch erst mal nice. Sobald man mit dem eigenen Telefon in die Nähe des Fahrrads kommt, öffnet es
sich. Geht man weg, schließt es sich ab. Ja, super. Ja, und würde das alles einfach nur über
die App und unverschlüsseltes Bluetooth funktionieren, wäre das ja zumindest temporär
kein Problem, wenn von MOV die Server abstellt. Weil die App liegt ja in den App-Stores von Apple
und Google. Dafür braucht man ja die von MOV-Server eigentlich nicht. Also zumindest,
solange die Smartphone-Betriebssysteme die App noch unterstützen. Nun ist es aber so,
dass die Bluetooth-Verbindung... Ähm, wisst ihr, was mir dabei auffällt? Also du brauchst die App,
um dein Fahrrad aufzuschließen. Klingt ja erst mal nach einer sinnvollen Idee und klingt auch
erst mal so, als würde das dazu führen, dass jemand sich das zweimal überlegt, das Fahrrad zu
klauen. Aber das Fahrrad muss ja für den Fall der Fälle, dass dein Handy kaputt geht, du dein Passwort
vergisst oder was auch immer, eine Möglichkeit des Resets bieten, um es neu zu pairen. Und da
kann man doch das Fahrrad einfach unter den Arm nehmen, wegtragen und Wegs Reset machen und neu
pairen, oder? Na gut, vielleicht wird dann der Standort angezeigt oder irgendwas. Ich weiß nicht,
wie die das dagegen... Ja, okay, ich weiß nicht, wie sie das gemacht haben. Aber du kriegst dann
bestimmt eine Nachricht. Irgendwie werden sie sich dafür schon was ausgedacht haben.
Noch unterstützen. Nun ist es aber so, dass die Bluetooth-Verbindung bei VanMoof grundsätzlich
verschlüsselt ist. Die App holt sich bei jeder Nutzung vom VanMoof-Server einen digitalen Schlüssel
ab und kommt ja nicht, weil die Server down sind. Kann man sich auf den Kopf stellen,
dann lässt sich das Smartphone nicht mehr mit dem Fahrrad verbinden. Das heißt,
man kann nichts mehr einstellen, aufschließen und einschalten kann man auch nicht mehr. Es
scheint zwar so zu sein, dass die Keys für eine Zeit auf dem Handy gespeichert werden,
aber definitiv nicht für ewig. Und wenn das Handy kaputt geht, ist natürlich sowieso Feuer.
Ja und eine wirklich einfach zu bedienende Alternative gibt es bislang nur für die
VanMoof-Modelle der 3er-Serie, also S3, X3. Da hat die Konkurrenzfirma Cowboy eine Alternativ-App
für Android- und iOS-Smartphones rausgebracht. Die holt sich die Sicherheitsschlüssel vom
VanMoof-Server, speichert die auf dem Telefon und bildet dann auch die Grundfunktionen der
VanMoof-Original-App nach. Da ist man dann erstmal auf der sicheren Seite und kann das
Rad auch weiter per App steuern. Aber es geht immer noch über die Cowboy-Server dann, oder wie?
Ja, auch wenn die VanMoof-Server abgeschaltet werden. Na okay,
es speichert lokal auf dem Handy. Und wir haben uns hier mal so ein S1 und S3
hingestellt und gucken jetzt mal, was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn man nicht die Hersteller-App
benutzt. Kommt man da trotzdem irgendwie dran? Wir haben die Baiki-App ausprobiert. Funktioniert
problemlos mit dem S3. Man kann damit zwar nicht komplett alle Einstellungen der Original-VanMoof-App
vornehmen, also zum Beispiel ganz detailliert die Schaltstufen, aber die wichtigsten Dinge
klappen. Also vor allem Fahrrad entsperren, Unterstützung zum Beispiel ganz detailliert
die Schaltstufen. Am Mac-Adresse wurde ausgeblendet. Wurde nicht wirklich komplett ausgeblendet?
Schauen wir mal, ob der Cutter... Ha! Ich hab's doch gesehen! Leaked! Chat,
Fahrrad übernehmen direkt. Let's go. Seid ihr schon drin, ja? Nee, nicht schlimm. Passiert
wahrscheinlich einfach gar nichts. Mal gucken, ob sich schon jemand in den Comments geschrieben hat,
dass man die Macs sehen kann. Die Leute freuen sich immer wahnsinnig, wenn sie sowas finden.
Mac. Nee, anscheinend nicht, okay. Hat anscheinend niemand entdeckt. Aber die wichtigsten Dinge
klappen. Also vor allem Fahrrad entsperren, Unterstützungsstufen einstellen und natürlich
am allerwichtigsten den Hupen-Sound festlegen. Ganz wichtig. Zum Einloggen braucht man dann
tatsächlich nicht mehr das VanMoof-Login und Passwort, sondern sagt einfach Import Key,
wählt die lokal gespeicherte Datei aus und zack ist man mit dem Fahrrad verbunden. Ziemlich cool.
Beim S1 konnten wir mit der Bikey-App nur den Sicherheitsschlüssel sichern, aber leider nicht
das Rad bedienen oder entsperren. Cowboy hat schon angekündigt, demnächst auch VanMoof-Fahrräder der
S5, X5-Serie zu unterstützen. Wer allerdings ein VanMoof der 1er, 2er oder 4er Serie hat,
schaut zurzeit in die Röhre. Was man aber unbedingt schon mal machen sollte, wenn man
so ein VanMoof-Rad hat. Den Key sichern. Mit dem exotischen Key-Exporter von Justus Dietrich und
Marius Angelmann einmal den Schlüssel fürs eigene Rad vom VanMoof-Server ziehen. Ja,
solange das noch geht. Womöglich wird dann noch Software kommen, die die VanMoof-App-Funktionalität
nachbildet und mit lokal auf dem Telefon gespeicherten Keys funktioniert. Was man
ebenfalls unbedingt machen sollte, solange die Server noch aktiv sind, den manuellen
Fahrrad-Einschalt-Code aktivieren. Damit kann man nämlich mit so einem Morse-Code-artigen
Tastendrücken das Rad entsperren. Das geht dann künftig auch ohne gekoppeltes Handy.
Macht man das aber alles nicht und wartet einfach ab und VanMoof stellt die Server aus,
ja, dann kann man im schlimmsten Fall wirklich nichts mehr mit dem Rad anfangen. Obendrein
gibt es aber auch noch andere Risiken. Da habe ich mal Stefan gefragt, der testet für CT-E-Bikes.
Durch die alternativen Apps ist man schon in der Lage, dass man das Rad im Prinzip bis
in alle Ewigkeit benutzen kann, aber es werden Funktionen wegfallen. Zum Beispiel die GPS-Ortung,
wo man in der App sehen kann, wo sich das Fahrrad gerade befindet. Stimmt, ja, sowas muss ja über
den Hersteller-Server gehen. Das wird irgendwann nicht mehr funktionieren. Die Fahrräder haben
ja im Moment auch noch einen Datentarif und kommunizieren mit den Servern. Wenn die Server
abgeschaltet werden, wird VanMoof irgendwann auch direkt... Moment, die Fahrräder haben eine
SIM-Karte drin. Ja gut, muss ja, muss ja. Wie soll das sonst seine GPS-Daten senden können?
Muss, muss es ja. Da ist eine SIM-Karte drin. Braucht ja nicht viel Daten, ja. Und das ist,
das ist günstig. Sowas gibt es ja schon für 5 Euro oder 2,50 im Monat oder sowas,
so Datentarife für ein paar 100 MB. Das reicht ja, GPS-Daten sind ja nicht groß. Und wenn du da alle,
keine Ahnung, alle halbe Stunde mal an einen Standort schickst, wenn es sich bewegt hat,
dürfte, dürfte das nicht viel Daten sein. Für die eingebauten SIM-Karten, die Datenmodems,
die in den Rädern drin sind, nicht mehr bezahlen. Das Rad wird wahrscheinlich auch
immer eine Fehlanmeldung im Display anzeigen und der Service von VanMoof, dass diese sogenannten
Bike Hunter, die ein geklautes Fahrrad orten und zurückbringen, dem wird es dann aller
Voraussicht auch nicht mehr geben. Danke. Ja und all das zeigt recht anschaulich,
was der Always Connected Internet of Things Smart Trend für riesige Nachteile hat. Okay,
kaufe ich mir ein digitales Videospiel oder einen Film bei Anbietern wie Steam oder Amazon,
dann ist mein Kauf weg, wenn der Anbieter kein Geld mehr hat und die Server abschaltet. Daran
haben wir uns allerdings schon gewöhnt und da gibt es ja zumindest Alternativen. Die meisten
Spiele kann man, wenn man das will, immer noch physisch auf Datenträgern kaufen und Blu-rays
gibt es ja auch, also noch. Dass man aber nun auch bei größeren Anschaffungen wie Fahrrädern,
Autos, Staubsauger-Robotern oder was auch immer inzwischen darauf achten muss, dass die Teile
womöglich wertlos werden, wenn die Hersteller pleite gehen und die Server abschalten, ist,
glaube ich, noch nicht in allzu vielen Köpfen angekommen. Aber stellt euch nur mal vor,
ihr kauft... Überlegt euch mal, das trifft ja teilweise auch auf neue Kühlschränke zu,
wo die Leute der Meinung sind, wir kaufen einen Kühlschrank, der besonders smart ist und dann
denkt sich der Hersteller, hat sich doch nicht so gut verkauft, wir geben jetzt mal hier Notice
und in einem Jahr schalten wir es ab. Na geil. Dann hast du zwar ein großes Display an deinem
Kühlschrank vorne dran, aber je nachdem, wie viel Cloud-Funktionalität das benutzt,
geht es dann halt einfach nicht mehr. Das ist halt voll für den Arsch. Ich meine,
ich habe einen Katzenbrunnen und normalerweise braucht das Ding Internetverbindungen,
damit man es steuern kann. Es geht zwar auch lokal, aber dann nicht sonderlich lange. Das
Ding, das braucht alle einmal in der Woche eine Verbindung zum China-Chinesen-Server,
ansonsten stellt es die Funktionalität ein. Der Knopf geht dann glaube ich noch,
aber das Bedienen über WLAN geht nicht mehr. Das ist halt schon extrem hängen geblieben.
Schauen wir mal, ob irgendwie einer da Custom-Firmware-Figur schon gebaut hat. Man weiß
ja nie. Nee, scheinbar nicht. Soweit sind wir schon, ja. Tesla für eine, sagen wir mal,
sechsstellige Summe. Ja, was passiert, wenn der Hersteller pleite geht und die Server abstellt?
Welche Funktionen gehen dann alle nicht mehr? Ich finde, diese Fragen muss man sich vor dem Kauf
stellen und die müssen die Hersteller einem eigentlich auch beantworten. Ist klar, die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass solche Riesenfirmen wie Amazon, Apple oder Microsoft, bei Tesla bin ich
mir nicht so sicher, den Betrieb einstellen. Nein, die stellen nicht den Betrieb ein,
aber die werden halt das machen, was beispielsweise mit alten Gameservern passieren wird. Die sagen
vielleicht nach einer Zeit X, das lohnt sich nicht mehr, das weiter zu betreiben. Ganz im
Ernst, stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid ein Hersteller, der verkauft Kühlschränke. Ihr habt jetzt einen
super krassen smarten Kühlschrank rausgebracht und die Leute kaufen den, aber ihr stellt fest,
nach irgendwie zwei, drei Jahren, das Ding hat sich nur irgendwie 800 mal verkauft und wir
betreiben dafür richtig viel Infrastruktur und Entwickler und alles und irgendwie hat sich das
nicht so wirklich gelohnt, diese Produktreihe und ihr stellt die ein und dann sagt ihr,
okay, wie lange sollen wir denn jetzt die Server weiter betreiben oder wie lange sollen wir noch
die Smartphone-Apps updaten? Und dann sagt ihr dann als Hersteller, okay, wir schreiben jetzt,
das Ding geht end of life und die Server laufen noch ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre, dass du auch
garantiemäßig alles abgedeckt hast, falls sich jemand neu gekauft hat, sagt er zwei Jahre noch.
Und dann hast du nach, sagen wir mal, drei oder vier Jahren, wenn das Ding nicht erfolgreich
gelaufen ist, einen Kühlschrank, wo die Hälfte der Funktionen nicht mehr funktioniert,
weil der Hersteller der Meinung ist, oh ne, wir schalten das jetzt ab. Das ist durchaus realistisch.
Auf der anderen Seite, was soll der Hersteller machen, wenn das nicht erfolgreich war? Sollen
sie es 30 Jahre betreiben und mal ganz davon abgesehen, neue Smartphone-Versionen unterstützen
die App dann zunehmend weniger, schlechter und manche Sachen gehen dann nicht mehr,
selbst wenn man das einfach nur so auf Legacy-Modus oder auf Maintenance-Modus
online lässt und nichts mehr updatet, was ist mit Sicherheitsproblemen und vor allem,
was ist mit neuen Smartphone-Versionen und der App, die dann vielleicht nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert. Also das muss man sich ernsthaft überlegen, ob man Sachen für viel Geld kaufen
möchte, also wo man viel Geld für Zusatzfunktionen ausgeben möchte, neben den normalen Basic-Funktionen
wie Kühlen, was so ein Kühlschrank hat und man dann ohne diese Funktionen da sitzen möchte,
im Zweifelsfall 3-4 Jahre später, sollte es Probleme geben. Warum hast du Chromium und
Chromebyte? Ja, warum nicht? Hier habe ich den Chat auf, hier habe ich YouTube auf, warum nicht?
Ich habe sogar noch Firefox zusätzlich und für ganz harte Leute, ich hätte sogar noch ein Edge
zu bieten. Das wäre in der Tat das Beste, aber da haben die Hersteller ja keinen Bock drauf. Also
ich persönlich wäre sofort dafür, wenn Hersteller bei jedem ihrer Produkte, die müssen nicht
zwangsläufig die Anwendung selbst Open Source machen, die Anwendung, aber zumindest eine klare
API-Dokumentation, dass wenn man das reimplementieren möchte, das machen kann. Aber vergiss es,
das wird es halt so nicht geben oder gibt es bei wenigen Sachen. Da muss man sagen, da ist der
Hersteller von meiner, von meinem Ladegerät für das Elektroauto. Die sind da ganz gut. Ich habe
ein, wie heißt das Ding? Ego, hier, so ein Teil habe ich. GoE, Charger, Home, Fix und was haben
die denn für Zubehör eigentlich? Passendes Zubehör für dein E-Auto. Okay, ein Kabel brauche ich jetzt
nicht wirklich oder was gibt es denn da tolles? Was haben die für Zubehör? Okay, die sind alle
furchtbar glücklich, weil sie jetzt diesen Charger haben. Also es wäre nicht möglich, dass der Vater
ein bisschen Gitarre spielt für das Kind ohne das Ladegerät und dass der mit der Fernbedienung auf
dem Sofa sitzt, wäre ohne das E-Auto-Ladegerät auch nicht möglich. Verstehe, verstehe. Was haben
die denn hier zu bieten? Das bringt mir nichts. Okay, es gibt Ladekabel, da habe ich schon welche,
das brauche ich nicht nochmal. Nützliche Helfer, Kabelhalterung Typ 2. Ich habe daneben, daneben
ist ein Wasserhahn, da lege ich das immer drauf. Braucht man nicht RFID-Tags? Teile deine
Ladestation mit dem Nachbarn. Zumindest, warum ich euch das eigentlich zeigen wollte, die muss
man, die muss man tatsächlich mal loben. Oh, was ist das für ein Ding? Der GoE-Controller. Maximiere
die Nachricht. Also das ist für, verstehe, habe ich, habe ich ja noch keine. Mal gucken, so wie
sich das preislich aktuell darstellt und mit Handwerker und so werde ich wahrscheinlich auch
nicht so schnell eine Solaranlage auf dem Dach haben. Was ich bei denen richtig gut finde,
die Firmware ist zwar meines Wissens nach nicht Open Source, glaube ich zumindest,
aber die haben, wie man hier sieht, die haben ihre API-Specs online. Das ist schon mal ganz
nice. Du kannst beispielsweise Cloud-API dir angucken, wie das, wie das funktioniert und
auch wie die lokale API funktioniert. Die haben nämlich die Möglichkeit, dass du lokal über das
WLAN zugreifst und deine komplette, dein komplettes Ladegerät steuern kannst ohne Cloud. Du kannst
das bei denen auch mit der Cloud verbinden, aber es geht alles auch ohne Cloud und dadurch, dass
die APIs öffentlich verfügbar sind und dokumentiert sind, wie die funktionieren,
kann jeder Integrationen bauen für das Ladegerät. Und das coole ist, die unterstützen als API sowohl
HTTP-API, TCP-API und MQTT-API. Das heißt, es gibt selbstverständlich schon eine fertige Home
Assistant Integration dafür, die über MQTT geht und die benutze ich im Endeffekt auch,
falls das die hier ist. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich die Integration benutze,
aber ja, das funktioniert an den Kombinationen. Also so, das finde ich auch okay, so dass man es
lokal steuern kann, dass man weiß, wie man es lokal steuern kann und dass man im Zweifelsfall
auch eine lokale API irgendwie nachbauen könnte, wenn man der Hersteller offline ist, was in dem
Fall nicht notwendig ist. Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Also das muss ich sagen, das hat der
Hersteller gut gemacht und es war auch eines der Gründe, warum ich mir dieses Teil gekauft habe,
weil das lokale Steuerungsmöglichkeiten hat. Und ich finde, es sieht eigentlich auch ganz
nice aus. Die haben RGB-LEDs hier drumherum, das sieht man jetzt normalerweise gar nicht.
Die leuchten dann in unterschiedlichen Farben, je nachdem, wie weit das Chargen ist. Wisst ihr
übrigens, ratet mal, auf welchem Microcontroller das Ding basiert. Kommt euch das Ding irgendwie
bekannt vor da hinten in der Ecke? Kommt euch das Teil irgendwie bekannt vor? Das sieht halt
einfach aus wie so ein 0815-Node-MCU-Modul. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es ein ESP8266
oder ein ESP32 ist. Ich glaube sogar, dass es ein ESP8266 noch ist. Gucken wir mal,
vielleicht sieht man es hier besser. Also vom Modul her würde ich eher sagen, ein ESP8266,
auch mit den Pins hier. So hundertprozentig sagen kann man es nicht. Aber es ist glaube ich ein
ESP8266. Ja, so sieht es aus. Und das war der Grund, warum ich mir das Teil gekauft habe. Einfach,
weil du es gut lokal steuern kannst. Ist ziemlich gering, aber ganz ausschließend kann man das
nicht. Ich meine, VanMoof war noch vor wenigen Jahren der absolute Überflieger im E-Bike-Business.
Ja, warum sind die eigentlich pleite? Ich dachte, das hat sich so gut verkauft.
200 Millionen US-Dollar Risikokapital eingeworben. Das war ein Erfolgsunternehmen. Ganz genau kann
man noch nicht sagen, wie es zum finanziellen Niedergang bei VanMoof überhaupt kam. Vermutlich
waren das Qualitätsprobleme und überbordende Reparaturkosten. Oder Management hat es verkackt.
Aber eigentlich ist das ja auch egal. Wichtig ist nur, dass die Leute, die die Fahrräder gekauft
haben, jetzt ein Problem haben. Und das finde wahrscheinlich nicht nur ich hochproblematisch.
Wie seht ihr das? Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare. Auf jeden Fall Augen auf beim
Kauf von smarten Dingen. Tschüss. Das stimmt. Oh, die YouTube-Polizei ist wieder am Start,
Leute. Der Titel ist nicht ganz korrekt ausgedrückt. Solche Produkte werden nicht
zu Elektroschrott. Sie sind bereits beim Kauf Elektroschrott. Hä? Okay. Actually,
genau. Es kommt drauf an, was kaputt ist. Also ich denke mal, ein Großteil dieses Fahrrads wird
ja ganz normales Fahrrad Technik sein. Also wenn da jetzt mal irgendwie die Kette kaputt geht oder so,
das wird ja schon jemand reparieren können. Aber sollte halt beispielsweise das Schloss nicht mehr
richtig funktionieren und sowas, da wirst du wahrscheinlich auf verlorenen Posten stehen,
dass das repariert wird. Das sind in dem Fall ja heiße User, aber das sind eher YouTube-Kommentierer,
die so dummes Zeug schreiben. Ich habe auch unter meinen Videos gibt es erstaunlich wenig
nervige Leute, aber ab und zu gibt es doch mal welche. Der Akku ist fest verbaut, das weiß ich
nicht. Wahrscheinlich. Also kannst du das Ding, wenn es viel benutzt, wahrscheinlich in 5, 6 Jahren
wegschmeißen. Oder wahrscheinlich sogar nur in 3, 4, weil vielleicht haben es ja Leute schon 3,
4 Jahre. Was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes? I seriously almost just got hacked. Das ist doch
Chebait, das Video. Das muss Chebait sein. Max, können wir über die Apple-Brille reden? Da gibt
es doch nicht allzu viel zu reden. In ein paar Jahren können wir mal gucken. Das ist jetzt ja
quasi eher was für Entwickler. Und in 2, 3 Jahren, wenn es dann eine normale Consumer-Variante
davon gibt und vielleicht die Entwickler schon ein paar coole Anwendungsideen hatten und Apps
gebaut haben und sowas. Dann können wir mal darüber reden, aber aktuell gibt es da ja noch
nicht so viel zu sagen. Ich glaube Fun-Move-Fahrräder kriegt man aktuell ziemlich billig. Lass uns mal
gucken. Kann man sowas bei Amazon kaufen? Ne, kann man nicht. Was kostet denn sowas? Shopping. Ich
würde sagen geht ja, aber im Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass die Dinger halt aktuell kurz
vor nicht mehr funktionieren sind, vielleicht doch keine so gute Idee. Da wird schon ordentlich.
Ahja, okay, man kann nichts Neues mehr bestellen. Schon ordentlich. Lecker. Lecker Amsterdam. Aber
das ist doch kein Vergleich. Wenn du ein Fahrrad haben willst, willst du ein Fahrrad und kein
Gebrauchtwagen, weil du Fahrrad fahren willst und nicht Auto fahren willst. Moin. Doch, ich weiß
nicht, was los ist, aber gestern war der Tag der Dorffeste. Dort, wo ich laufen war, Dorffest. Dort,
wo ich zurück war, zurück vom Laufen kommen, Dorffest. Dann bin ich bei mir hier rumgelaufen,
an zwei Stellen, Fest. War gestern irgendwas? Habe ich irgendwas verpasst? War 22.7.? Ist da
irgendwas? Ja, keine Ahnung, was da los ist. Warum? Ja, bei uns an der Kirche auch, Fest,
alles. Weiß nicht, was 22.7. ist. Mein Vatertag und so ist ja schon vorbei. Okay,
also, I seriously, das ist G-Bait. Das ist so krasser G-Bait, das Video. Okay. Nein, okay.
Okay. Ich sag noch nichts, wir gucken mal weiter.
Wisst ihr, was ganz einfach ist? Wie man komplett diesen Problemen aus dem Weg gehen kann? Solche
Sachen einfach unter Linux in der VM machen. Mach ich auch. Also, wenn ich irgendwelche E-Mails
kriege mit Anhängen und sonst was, ich mach einfach mal Linux VM auf, mail und guck da rein,
da hast du die Probleme alle nicht. Das eigentliche Problem ist, diesen ganzen Shit unter
Windows machen zu wollen.
Ja, okay, leider. Okay.
Schon mal gut. Und Console App 1, prinzipiell der beste Name dafür.
Das mache ich nie. Das ist tatsächlich ein
Problem. Das mache ich aber nie. Ich gehe immer auf die, ich gucke mir immer die GitHub-Seite davon
an. Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem. Das ist übrigens, ein ähnliches Problem gibt es mit jedem
Package Manager. Auch bei NPM und Python und so. Bei NPM haben sie es mittlerweile wenigstens so
gemacht, dass keine Post Install Scripts und so mehr standardmäßig ausgeführt werden. Aber du
kannst dir selbstverständlich mit einem Package Manager einfach unendlich viel Shit auf deinen
Rechner holen. Ja.
Okay, da weißt du schon, da ist der G-Bait.
Hi Max, kann mir eventuell jemand helfen, wenn du sehen willst, was in Linux alles installiert ist.
RPM minus QA, QL? Oder was ist denn für eine Distribution? Was ist es für eine Distribution?
L-Pine weiß ich nicht. Mint, Abt, Abtlist, Abtlist. Abtlist minus minus install, meinetwegen. Ja,
okay. Ja, ja. Oder dpkg minus, ne, minus L ist es, ne? Minus I ist install. Ja, easy. Easy. Wir
sollten Consulting Gebühren nehmen. Guck, ich kann dir sogar live zeigen. Pass mal auf. Docker,
run, Ubuntu. Funktioniert das so? Docker, run, Ubuntu. Wie ich mir das immer nicht merken kann.
Minus minus am. Ah ja, hier, guck, da, da. Alles klar, so. Da, guck. Abt, List,
minus minus install. Zack, da siehst du, was du installiert hast. Easy. Easy. Easy. Okay. Weiter
gucken. Rest. Also wie gesagt, ich würde mir immer mal den Source Code zur Gemüte führen
davon. Xbox. Ah, Discord. Okay, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich so malicious Package gedönst
auf Nougat sehe. NPM ist ja Standard, dass da laufend irgendein Bullshit ist und gerade
irgendwie die Hälfte der neu veröffentlichten NPM Packages sind irgendwie Bullshit. Oder Werbung,
ist auch geiler Trend, dass Werbung auf NPM veröffentlicht wird. Kein Witz jetzt. Wird
gespammt auf NPM. Ja, verdächtig, verdächtig.
Verdächtig.
Warum baut Microsoft immer so einen Shit ein? Auf der einen Seite geben sie sich mega viel Mühe,
das sicherer zu machen und dann haben sie noch so viel Shit drin,
wo alle anderen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen wieder unterkrebt.
Der Name klingt schon sehr vertrauenserweckend, ja.
Also das erste, was ich jetzt gemacht hätte, wäre mal mein Netzwerkkabel rausziehen. Wenn
ich den Rechner weiter benutzen möchte, um zu analysieren. Ich würde jetzt an der Stelle
spätestens, hätte ich mein Netzwerkkabel rausgezogen.
Was ist denn noch besser? Wir sind am Programmieren mit Rider unter Linux. Da hat man zwar
potenziell eventuell ähnliche Probleme, aber es ist zumindest ein isoliertes Environment.
Also das stimmt, aber das Beste ist erstmal, sich überhaupt das Projekt anzugucken. Also
wenn das Projekt schon mal keine, ich meine, wir können uns das doch mal anschauen hier jetzt. So,
wir machen mal ein Snapshot. Wer weiß, wer weiß, was Sache ist, ja. Wir können uns das doch mal
kurz anschauen. Ich hoffe, wahrscheinlich ist nach dem Video das Package sogar schon wieder weg.
Übrigens, nice am Frühstücken, der Pepo hier. Console App 2, beste. Nougat Package,
Nougat Package, wo haben sie es denn hin? Sind sie da versteckt? Nougat Package. OpenAI hat
er gesucht, gell? Ich finde das Package gar nicht von ihm. Es hieß einfach nur OpenAI.
Wahrscheinlich ist es entfernt. Kann das sein, dass es entfernt ist mittlerweile? Nougat. OpenAI
und dann sortieren wir mal nach Downloads. Hier, das da, gell? Das hier. Von OggoDoIt.
Source Repository. Ne, das war ein anderes, weil das ist ein bekanntes Open Source Projekt Package.
Das ist was anderes. Es ist weg. Es ist weg anscheinend. Anscheinend ist es weg. Die waren
schnell aktiv und haben es gelöscht. Wir gucken noch mal kurz. Wir sind bei 3,54. Bei Nougat
Solutions. Nougat Solutions. Ich glaube, man kann nach dem User vielleicht suchen. Nougat. Kann
man suchen nach? Ne. Okay, die haben den Typ wahrscheinlich gelöscht. Vermutlich. Ich trinke
keine Energy Drinks. Keine Ahnung, wie das schmeckt. Ich trinke auch so gut wie keinen
Kaffee. Ich trinke eher Tee. Den ganzen Tag. Ja, Antrax.bat klingt natürlich schon sehr
vertrauenserweckend.
Ja, das beste Feature ist, einfach Linux zu verwenden, in dem Fall. Ja, whitelist ist böse,
darf man nicht mal sagen. Okay, das war es doch eigentlich schon, oder? Das ist alles,
um was es hier ging.
Ja. Ja, und? Was hat es gemacht?
Ah.
Kannst du schon mal Support über Telegram holen, ja? Wirkt alles äußerst vertrauenserweckend.
Ja, okay. Oh, ne. Ne, bloß keine 5-Kubanit-Cluster daheim jetzt. Ja. Ja, das kann ja relativ
easy passieren. Übrigens, das ist jetzt nichts Visual Studio.net-spezifisches, also in dem Fall
schon. Aber insgesamt, die ganzen Package Manager haben so Probleme. Also ich rede jetzt nicht von
den offiziellen Package Managern von einem Linux-System. Die haben so Probleme eher nicht,
weil das sind ja offizielle Paketquellen mit Hash, alles gesichert mit Checksum. Da gibt es keine
Probleme. Aber PIP oder NPM oder NuGet oder sowas, da hast du potenziell schon Probleme.
Ich reboote mal. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Ackermans am Start. Das kann uns übrigens nicht
passieren. Wir sind unter Linux in Rider unterwegs und installieren prinzipiell nur NuGet-Packages,
wo wir vorher das GitHub kontrolliert haben, was da eigentlich abgeht. Ich meine,
nicht alles im Detail, aber allein schon, wenn ein Public GitHub Repo existiert,
da schafft es schon ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen. Ob das jetzt exakt das ist, was als NuGet
angeboten wird, das können wir natürlich auch so nicht ohne weiteres verifizieren. Ja,
dann müsste man das Package selbst bauen. Das macht ja kaum einer. Welche Fonts muss ich installieren,
damit die Icons gehen mit deiner Config? Du brauchst... Also ein Emoji-Font brauchst du
erstmal nicht, auch wenn es praktisch ist. Du brauchst... Ich glaube Powerline. Packman-QL?
Wow. TTF? Moment. Packman-List-Installed-Packages. Ach ne, es ist einfach nur Q. Du brauchst
wahrscheinlich... Wahrscheinlich das hier. Patched-Hack-Font from NerdFonts-Library. Ja,
das brauchst du. Und ich habe zwei davon. Ich habe Meslo installiert und ich habe Hack
installiert mit gepatchten Symbols. Weil ich glaube, das hier oben ist Meslo und nicht Hack.
Meslo ist, glaube ich, der Apple-Font. Also das sind die Fonts, die ich installiert habe hier.
Ach ja und Adobe-Source-Code habe ich auch noch installiert für China-Chinesen. China-Chinesen-Buchstaben
in GitHub. Wie ist die Meinung zu Xamarin? Gibt's ja nicht mehr. Es gibt jetzt Maui und Maui mag ich
nicht. Und Xamarin mochte ich auch schon nicht. Ja, das stimmt. Aber du kannst dir zumindest,
wenn du es mit dem offiziellen Package-Manager installierst, relativ sicher sein, dass es sicher
ist. Das kommt aus offiziellen Quellen und es sind auch quasi beim Installieren werden ja auch
abgeglichen die Hash-Werte, ob das wirklich das offizielle Package ist. Also mit dem normalen
Package-Manager würd ich mir da keine Gedanken machen. Ja, bei Pip und bei Nougat und bei NPM
und so sieht es wieder anders aus. Doch, kann man. Kann man, aber ich mag beides nicht. So. Oh,
da. Er will es ganz genau wissen. Ja, das stimmt. Du kannst natürlich in deinen Package-Manager auch
nicht getrustete Package-Quellen hinzufügen. Das stimmt. Kannst du machen. Dann bist du aber
selbst ziemlich pipega. Aber kannst du machen. Natürlich. Du kannst in deine Sources-List oder
in deine YAM-Repo, wie heißt das Ding, YAM-Repos, D-Repos, YAML oder was auch immer,
da kannst du auch irgendwelche untrusted Repos reinschreiben. Aber standardmäßig,
wenn du dein Betriebssystem installierst und einen standardmäßig mitgelieferten
Package-Manager verwendest, mit den offiziellen Paket-Quellen, dann würd ich mir wenig Gedanken
machen. Was empfiehlst du für Android-App-Development? Keine Ahnung. Ich mach kein
Android-App-Development. Das einzige, was wir mal gemacht haben, ist, wir haben versucht aus
der offiziellen Fiat-App irgendwelche Sachen mitzusniffen. Dafür hab ich den Emulator im
Android-Studio benutzt. Aber wir haben noch keine, also die einzigen Sachen, die ich mal gemacht hab,
die ein bisschen sich App-ähnlich verhalten, das war Web-Service mit PWA. Da konntest du dann
die PWA auf deinem Smartphone installieren. Jetzt war es natürlich keine vollwertige App,
weil Betriebssystem-Integration nicht so eng möglich war, aber es war eh hauptsächlich ein
Web-Service. Und der hat unter Android am besten funktioniert, die App, weil Android
Web-Notifications kann und iOS ja bis heute keinen Bock hat auf Web-Notifications. Oder,
geht das mittlerweile? Oh, wie, das geht mittlerweile? Ah ne, Safari und iOS.
Requires website to be first added to. Ach ja, das geht mittlerweile tatsächlich. Aha,
das ist natürlich nicht schlecht. Schon mal gut zu wissen, dass mittlerweile anscheinend
Web-Notifi-gehen, da wär ich mir trotzdem nicht so sicher, auch wenn das hier steht,
dass Web-Notifications gehen für PWAs auf dem Homescreen. Okay, wäre sehr nice,
wenn das funktioniert. Klar, da gibt's jede Menge Worts von. Musst du im Archiv gucken,
gibt's jede Menge Worts von. Guck, Archiv. Hab doch auf YouTube sogar letztens ne Playlist
gesehen. Ja, hier sind alle Worts vom Fiat Champ. Gibt's eigentlich manchmal Comments
auf dem Channel. Beliebt. iOS-Flashen. Quatsch mit Soße. POG-Subscription. Dankeschön.
Cute. Bei mir geht das mit Windows Key plus D nicht, dass ich Programme ausführe mit
der E3-Config. Muss ich da noch was Spezielles installieren? Du meinst das hier? Ja, musst
du. Du musst diesen Launcher installieren dafür. Guck, wenn du in meine E3-Config guckst.
Redest du jetzt von meiner E3-Config oder von deiner Default-E3-Config? Für die E3-Default-Config
brauchst du D-Menü, glaube ich. Und für meine brauchst du, siehst du auch hier, musst du
Rovi installiert haben. Siehst du auch hier. Guck, was der ausführt. Der führt das hier aus. Unter
der Haube. Da musst du den hier installiert haben. Und dafür habe ich auch gleich die Config hier
mit dabei. Ich benutze das für Windows-Taste D zum Starten von Programmen. Und ich benutze das P
für meinen Clipboard-Manager. Und du kannst noch mehr Sachen machen. Emojis einfügen. So,
was haben wir denn sonst noch? How Javascript ruined the web. Was haben wir hier? Das schlimmste
Spiel des Jahres und dessen Folge. Oh Gott. Oh nein. Please. Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt
angucken. Geht auch nur acht Minuten. Das war ja so ein Fail, Alter. Ich habe mir das von Anfang
an, ehrlich gesagt, bei diesem Game schon gedacht. Weil mal ehrlich, mal ehrlich, ja? Hat sich
irgendjemand... Ich meine, erstens, Herr der Ringe ist eh schon seit ein paar Jahren nicht
mal so super angesagt. Aber hat sich irgendjemand, der Herr der Ringe geguckt hat, überlegt,
Alter, ich wäre mal gerne Gollum. Niemand, keiner wollte je Gollum sein. ...bewiesen,
dass wir es einfach drauf haben. 2023 ist eigentlich ein ziemlich nices Jahr für Gaming. Es
kam zum Beispiel das raus und das und das und das raus und das und das und das und fuck. Unser
allerliebstes Charakter aus der Herr-der-Ringe-Welt Gollum hat sein eigenes Spiel bekommen. Es hat
komplett reingeschissen. Von vielen wird es als das schlechteste Spiel des Jahres bezeichnet. Es
war so ein Flop, dass das Entwicklerstudio kurze Zeit später schließen musste. Wir tauchen ein
wenig in die Gollum-Thematik ein, weil ich mir nichts Schöneres vorstellen kann als das. Let's go.
Moin Max, ich bin heute in Frankfurt. Was kannst du empfehlen? Essen, Burger lehnen, Döner lehnen?
Ich war ganz lange in Frankfurt nichts mehr großartig futtern, weil ich hauptsächlich
Homeoffice mache. Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Klingt jetzt blöd, aber ich kann dir nichts
Gescheites empfehlen. Also was richtig gut ist, wo du sagst, oh ja, da muss man unbedingt hin. Also
wenn du einfach nur auf die schnelle Mittagessen willst, kannst du zum Mexikaner gehen, wo wir auch
ab und zu mal hingehen. Das ist aber eher so eine Subway-mäßige Kette. Ja, das Teil in Frankfurt,
ja. Nein, nein. Ja, so sieht das aus. Also das ist auf der, der Kaiserstraße irgendwo. Also wenn du
am Bahnhof bist, kommst du da easy hin. Ja. Das ist jetzt nicht sagen, würde ich nicht sagen,
dass das super geil ist, aber wenn man mal schneller, wenn man mal schnell was Mittag
fressen, futtern will, ist das ganz okay. Also vom Hauptbahnhof dahin dauert ungefähr zehn Minuten
hin, zehn Minuten zurück. Ich würde aber gucken, dass du vor zwölf da, also dass du nicht zwischen,
zwischen zwölf und 13 Uhr dahin gehst. Vor zwölf ist so, vor 30 bis 12 ist okay und danach,
ansonsten ist es zu voll. Da war ich noch nicht. Und ich war lange in Frankfurt auch nichts mehr
großartig futtern, weil ich die letzten Jahre über fast nur Homeoffice gemacht habe und auch
vorhabe, das weiterhin so zu machen. Ich kann dir wirklich nichts Gescheites mehr empfehlen.
Viele Läden, wo ich früher hingegangen bin, die gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Gollum ist dieses eine Spiel, nach dem niemand gefragt hat. Herr der Ringe ist ein Universum.
Genau das denke ich mir auch. Niemand wollte je Gollum spielen.
Also voller magischer Welten und Charaktere. Wieso sollte man die nervigste und unnütze
Kreatur von allen nehmen? Das ist so, als würde man ein Videospiel.
Ich vermute mal, das haben die gemacht, weil die Marke billig oder das billig zu bekommen war.
Es hätte auch mit fast jedem anderen Hobbit irgendwie mehr Sinn gemacht.
Aber man kann nur den alten Jenkins spielen und das Gameplay besteht nur darin, im Park
spazieren zu gehen. Wahrscheinlich wäre das sogar cooler gewesen.
Gollum ist ein chilliger Side-Character an einem großen Epos wie Herr der Ringe,
ihn aber als Protagonisten viele Stunden am Stück in einem Videospiel. Ich wollte sterben.
Heizmaul. Er labert die ganze Zeit beim Spielen irgendeine Scheiße, was akkurat ist.
Das macht schließlich den Charakter von Gollum so ein bisschen aus.
Aber wer hat denn Bock darauf? Wer hat Bock?
Ich sag doch, wer hat Bock, Gollum zu spielen?
Umgesetzt wäre das noch mal eine andere Story gewesen, aber das Spiel ist so schlecht,
dass es weitaus größere Ausmaße annahm, als vermutlich jeder erwartet hat.
Verantwortliche für dieses Spiel sind der Delic Entertainment. Sitz in Hamburg,
also wahrlich ein deutsches Videospielentwicklerstudio.
Kennen tun viele dieses Studio vermutlich durch Spiele wie Edna bricht aus oder Deponia.
Das sind Point-and-Click-Adventure-Spiele, die vor allem durch ihren Humor geglänzt haben und
unfassbar gut angekommen sind, vor allem hier in Deutschland.
Solche Point-and-Click-Games sind so ein wenig ihr Steckenpferd geworden.
Es kamen über die Jahre viele Spiele dieser Art raus,
auch wenn sie zwischendrin trotzdem auch noch anderweitige Spiele entwickelt haben.
Mit der Zeit liefen diese Spiele aber immer schlechter.
So in der Erde floppte beispielsweise Harten.
Aufgrund interner Probleme verließen immer mehr Talente das Team.
Der einzige Weg, um aus dieser Abwärtsspirale rauszukommen, so glaubte man scheinbar,
war die Flucht nach vorne in eine große AAA-Produktion.
Not, not Stonks.
Übersteigt alles, was das Studio in der Vergangenheit gemacht hat.
Sie sind hiervon hierhin gesprungen.
Das Ziel war es, das Unternehmen mit einem großen Kracher wieder Gesprächsthema werden zu lassen.
Und ich meine, also irgendwie haben sie es geschafft.
Es wurde eine ordentliche Stange Geld in die Hand genommen, um das am...
Die haben ja schon quasi eine Woche nach Release irgendeine Entschuldigung veröffentlicht.
Die wurde wahrscheinlich im Vorfeld schon vorgeschrieben für den Fall der Fälle.
...ambitionierte Produkt erschaffen zu können, was von jedem angestrebt wurde.
Stellt sich heraus, dass das Spiel Müll ist.
Niemand hat es sich gekauft und das Studio musste schließen.
Das Spiel, das eigentlich deren Rettung werden sollte, wurde schließlich deren Untergang.
Gollum höchstpersönlich hat es geschafft, dass dieses Team nie wieder entwickeln wird.
Aber ist das gerechtfertigt?
Das Game war gar nicht so teuer im Vergleich zu vielen anderen AAA-Games.
Aber es war halt trotzdem...
Vielleicht hat ihnen auch die Kohle gefehlt.
Ich find's vom Ansatz her schon dumm.
Ich hätte nie Bock darauf, Gollum zu spiel...
...fertigt.
Ich hab mir das Spiel tatsächlich gekauft und ich kann euch gerne von meinen Erfahrungen berichten.
Story-Technisch spielt das Spiel zwischen den Handlungen aus Der Hobbit und Herr der Ringe, als Gollum eingesperrt war.
Man hat sich also den schrecklichsten Charakter genommen und gleichzeitig noch das schrecklichste Setting,
da man in dem Spiel die ganze Zeit im Knast ist und Sklavenarbeit verrichtet.
Man macht also das langweiligste, was man sich vorstellen kann.
Die Aufgaben, die man bekommt, beschränken sich im Endeffekt.
Gibt es sowas wie Hate-Playing?
Ein Hate-Watching und sowas gibt es.
Also vielleicht lohnt es sich unter dem Strich finanziell sogar doch ein bisschen,
weil so viele Leute es kaufen, um es zu haten.
...immer auf, geh von A nach B und folge dieser Person, was auch Sinn ergibt.
Gollum kann nicht wirklich was anderes machen, weil Gollum komplett useless ist.
Er ist eine wahnsinnige schizophrene Kreatur, die nix kann und genauso wenig kann er auch im Spiel,
außer rumhüpfen und rumklettern.
Die Animationen sind halt auch so schlecht, guckt euch das mal an.
Und das war jetzt noch eines der wohlwollenderen Sachen hier, guck mal.
Guck mal, das ist immer, es werden überhaupt nicht versucht, das zu interpolieren.
Du siehst einfach, wie er komplett von der normalen Bewegung zum nächsten Punkt snappt.
Guckt euch auch mal an, wie er jetzt hier dranspringt gleich, zack.
Und jetzt ist er instant attached da dran.
Es gibt kein richtiges Combat oder interessante Fähigkeiten, keine Ausrüstung,
nix was Gollum machen kann, außer rumzulaufen und irgendwelche Platforming-Passagen zu absolvieren.
Hier mal eine Wand hochlaufen, hier mal über ein paar Schluchten springen.
Das alles hätte vielleicht noch ganz schön...
Und vor allem die Gesichtsanimation, Alter, das ist das Schlimmste an dem Game.
Die resetten immer in so eine Art T-Pose-Gesichtsanimation nach jeder Mimik, die abgespielt wird.
...wäre das Weltendesign nicht unfassbar shit.
In Spielen wie Assassin's Creed macht es Spaß, in der Welt herumzuklettern, da man immer einen passenden Weg...
Assassin's Creed hat aber für seine Zeit immer absolut top Animations gehabt.
Ich muss sagen, am meisten beeindruckt, es gab ein paar Spiele, die mich wirklich extrem beeindruckt haben zu ihrer damaligen Zeit,
die, was Animationen angeht, das eine war Uncharted, eindeutig.
Uncharted hatte, finde ich, für die Zeit, und auch die späteren Teile, aber gerade beim ersten Teil, das war ja recht viel...
Mega, mega gute Animationen, vor allem halt auch, wie Drake auf die Umgebung reagiert hat.
So, du läufst gegen eine Wand, du läufst nicht einfach gegen eine Wand, er macht den Fuß gegen die Wand und stützt sich dagegen, so mega, mega nice.
Und das andere, ein bisschen unterm Radar gelaufen, Max Payne 3.
Max Payne 3 hat er auch richtig gut gemacht, was das angeht.
Ja, Assassin's Creed und so, die Offensichtlichen, ja, aber...
Tja, und Gollum hat halt auch gezeigt, wie man das 2023 hinbekommt, dass es mieser aussieht wie PS2-Spiele.
Weg suchen muss und alle schlauen die vorhandene Welt reindesignt wurde.
In Gollum ist es immer super offensichtlich, wo man hin muss mit weißen Kanten, an denen man sich festhalten kann und sonst nirgendwo anders.
Man kann von den offensichtlich vom Spiel vorgegebenen Routen nicht abkommen, was es nach kurzer Zeit schon...
Alter, das sieht so falsch aus einfach nur.
Ich meine, was hat er denn bitteschön für Kraft in den Ärmen, Alter, guckt euch das mal an.
Der springt mit den Ärmen dreimal höher als mit den Füßen.
...nach kurzer Zeit schon unfassbar langweilig werden lässt.
Oben drauf kommt noch Gollums schreckliches Gelaber die ganze Zeit und die Steuerung.
Ich bin gestorben, als ich das Spiel gespielt habe.
Sehr schwammige Steuerung, was in einem Spiel, was halt darauf ausgelegt ist, die ganze Zeit herumzuspringen, super nervig ist.
Ein anderes wichtiges Element in dem Spiel sind die Stealth-Abschnitte.
Wir müssen uns unseren Weg vorbahren, ohne entdeckt zu werden.
Ist auch nicht wirklich schwer, weil die AI in dem Spiel dumm wie Scheiße ist.
Das sieht schlechter aus wie ein PS2-Game, Alter.
Die Orks, die einen nicht erwischen dürfen, haben einen exakt festgelegten Pfad, der vorhersehbarer nicht sein kann.
Man kann buchstäblich genau neben ihnen stehen und die sehen einen nicht.
Man muss wirklich exakt in die offensichtlichen Spots laufen, die gerade bewacht werden, um hier erwischt zu werden.
Das alles ähnelt irgendwie Zelda vom Nintendo 64, wo man nicht von den Bächtern erwischt werden durfte.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass dieses Spiel hier älter als meine Oma ist.
Es ist einfach weder gut, noch irgendwie spaßig umgesetzt.
Es ist keine Challenge und es ist in vielen Fällen sogar eher lächerlich.
Von den ganzen Bugs und Glitches, die in diesem Spiel existieren, wollen wir gar nicht erst anfangen.
Ich will ja fair sein und es gab Sachen, die waren zumindest vom Gedankengang eigentlich echt cool.
Der gesamte Punkt von Gollum als Wesen ist, dass er ein verkommener Hobbit ist, der aufgeteilt zwischen zwei Persönlichkeiten ist.
Seinem eigentlichen Ich, Smergol und seiner wahnsinnigen Gollum-Seite.
Es gibt in dem Spiel Entscheidungen, die man tätigen muss und hier gibt es immer eine gute und eine böse.
Je nachdem, für welche man sich entscheidet, muss man entweder seine gute Hälfte oder seine schlechte Hälfte...
Sagt man sich... Ach, das sieht so unstimmig, einfach nur mies aus von der Optik her.
Wahrscheinlich hat es am Ende noch nicht mal irgendwelche Auswirkungen.
...Hälfte von der jeweiligen Entscheidung überzeugen, indem man mit sich selber diskutiert.
Von der Umsetzung her könnte...
Guck, hier sieht man es. Hier sieht man, wie die Animationen immer resetten wieder.
Habt ihr es gesehen? Na gut, das war jetzt ein bisschen überblendet.
Guck hier. Hier ist die Animation. Hier ist die Animation zu Ende.
Und jetzt kommt wieder so diese Standard-Animations-Teapause.
Von daher könnte es besser sein. Man muss in dieser Diskussion oft raten und hoffen, dass man die richtige Dialogentscheidung ausgewählt hat.
Aber ich finde die Mechanik an sich echt cool.
Außerdem cool ist der Fakt, dass die Dialoge der Elfen im Englisch, aber auch in Sindarin auf-
Ja Moment, Sindarin gibt es aber nur als DLC.
Das ist ja das Geile da drin.
Die wollen sogar, dass du extra für Voice-Acting in Elvisch bezahlst.
...genommen wurden. Das ist die Sprache der Elfen in Herr der Ringe.
Das sind einfach nice Details.
Man kann im Menü einstellen, was man lieber möchte, wenn man das Geld dafür-
Genau.
...bezahlt.
Ich liebe es, wenn in Spielen zum Release direkt ein ganz großer Punkt im Menü herunterladbare Inhalte sind.
Die haben das Sindarin einfach hinter einer 3-Euro-Paywall gestellt. Wow.
Und ähnlicher merkwürdiger Natur sind alle Ingame-Käufe in dem Spiel.
Man kann sich zum Beispiel ein Emote-Pack kaufen.
Ich muss Geld bezahlen, damit Gollum in dem Spiel meinen Schatz sagen kann.
Für 5 Euro kann man sich das Lore-Compendium kaufen, was eine große Ansammlung an Facts zur Herr-der-Ringe-Welt ist.
Ja, man kann auch einfach das Herr-der-Ringe-Wiki aufmachen.
Das ist super cool. Wieso muss man dafür obendrauf zahlen?
Das Game hat 50 Euro gekostet. Direkt einen Tag nachdem das Spiel rausge-
Genau. Jetzt kam erst mal die Entschuldigung.
Und ich wette mit euch, diese Entschuldigung wurde im Vorfeld formuliert, weil man schon geahnt hat, dass das Spiel kacke ankommt.
Komm, es hat Daedalic die obligatorische Entschuldigung gepostet.
Ein farbiger Screen, Logo, irgendein Rahmen, Text und zack Gaming in 2023.
Es ist quasi schon ein Ritual für Game-Publisher geworden, diese Texte zu posten.
Und das Beste ist, dass es bei jedem immer derselbe Text ist.
Wir haben verkackt. Es tut uns leid. Tschüss.
Bei Daedalic muss irgendwas gewaltig bei den Führungskräften schiefgelaufen sein,
da man schon inmitten der Entwicklung hätte merken müssen, dass dieses Projekt zum Scheitern verurteilt ist.
Das war wahrscheinlich, wie sagt man schon, too big to fail für die.
Sie haben ihr Entwicklerstudio komplett geschlossen und wollen fortan nur noch Spiele publishen, statt selbst zu entwickeln.
Das ist hart, da sie intern sogar schon an einem Nachfolger gearbeitet haben.
Okay, die sind komplett lost.
Alter, haben die wirklich gedacht, na egal, Management vielleicht, die sind wahrscheinlich...
Also, das ist ja eines der Hauptgründe für Unternehmen geht den Bach runter,
wenn Management Leute komplett von der Realität entkoppelt sind.
Was hier anscheinend der Fall gewesen ist.
Sie dachten, dass es so gut ankommt, dass sie einen Nachfolger dazu rausbringen können.
Das ist fast schon traurig.
Gollum ist das Ergebnis davon, ein Projekt eventuell nicht ganz bis zum Ende durchdacht zu haben,
da das alles von der Idee bis hin zur Möglichkeit, es umzusetzen, von vornherein zum Scheitern verurteilt war.
Wir können uns wohl darauf einigen, dass wir nie wieder über dieses Spiel reden
und alle einfach so tun, als wäre all das nie passiert.
Ja, oh man, Alter, wie sie es verkackt haben.
Das erinnert mich, die Story erinnert mich ein bisschen an, wie hieß dieser andere Adventure-Hersteller,
der dann auch immer teurere Lizenzen gekauft hat und die Spiele immer schlechter angekommen sind
und jetzt glaube ich gar nichts mehr.
Wie heißen die, die Minecraft-Story-Mode gemacht haben?
Ich komme nicht drauf. Ich meine, wir können googlen, aber vielleicht fällt es mir nur ein.
Telltale, genau.
Bei denen war es ja auch so, da ging es den Bach runter.
Leider werden wir Gollum 2 nie sehen.
Playing Minecraft on Windows 98
Das ist halt der typische Ding, wo man sich fragt, warum?
Aber wahrscheinlich ist die Antwort, weil es geht.
Minecraft Classic und nicht nur das.
Schaut mal, wie schnell es hier läuft.
Wir bekommen konstant über 100 FPS.
150 FPS.
Äh, welches...
...Level hier.
100, wir werden einfach nur...
Alles klar, also von links nach rechts...
Ja, warum auch nicht?
Ups.
Lass uns über die modernen...
Okay, was haben wir hier noch zu bieten?
Leute, ich kriege langsam schon Hunger.
How Javascript...
...Javascript, wie es die coolen Leute sagen...
...ruined the web.
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen und sagen, Javascript hat das Web überhaupt nicht ruiniert.
Sondern...
...mit zu dem gemacht, was es jetzt ist.
Ich meine, guckt mal, wie komplex und vielfältig von Funktionen Webanwendungen heutzutage sind.
Und es hat seinen Grund, dass Leute quasi 80% nur noch ihren Browser benutzen.
In der täglichen...
...Arbeit am Rechner oder am Smartphone oder so.
80% ist, würde ich mal sagen, ist Browser.
Und das ist Webanwendungen auch Javascript zu verdanken.
Also ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass es das Web ruiniert hat.
Das ist heute einfach anders als früher, aber von der Funktionalität her viel besser.
Macht sich natürlich im Titel besser, ja.
Everybody kind of knows how bad the modern web is these days.
And I'm sure you...
Okay, das modern Web ist nicht schlecht.
Ich muss sagen, auf dem Desktop sind viele Designentscheidungen mega kacke.
Zum Beispiel, dass viele Webseiten immer tabletartiger werden und sich tabletartiger bedienen lassen.
Zum Beispiel, bestes Beispiel dafür sind die YouTube-Kommentare.
Warum muss ich Endless-Scroll haben?
Endless-Scroll für YouTube-Comments ist der größte Bullshit ever.
Was die eingeführt haben, Usability-mäßig auf der Seite.
Das ist auf dem Smartphone vielleicht ganz cool, da kannst du eine halbe Stunde runterscrollen.
Aber such mal einen Kommentar, ja.
Also du kannst ja weder Kommentare suchen, ich weiß, es gibt Browser-Addons.
Aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, auf dem Desktop, ja.
Warum kann ich nicht einfach...
Und das funktioniert übrigens noch nicht mal richtig, wenn man die Stelle überscrollt, wo es Kommentare nachlädt.
Guck jetzt erst, wenn man da ist.
Warum könnte man nicht einfach sagen, okay, auf dem Desktop machen wir unten halt Pages.
Dann gehe ich auf Page 5 und finde das Comment wieder, oder?
Ich kann wenigstens, wenigstens die Kommentare durchsuchen.
Aber nein, die Basics der Basics geht's nicht, weil es irgendwie so eine Billig-Mobile-Anwendung geworden ist.
Nun gut, ja, da kann man sich drüber aufregen.
Aber über Modern Web an sich...
Eigentlich weniger?
Na gut, mal gucken, was er sagt.
Ja.
Ja, New Reddit habe ich noch nie verstanden, warum das so geil sein soll.
Ich meine, New Reddit sieht ein bisschen besser aus als Old Reddit.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen, und das könnt ihr mir jetzt ja mal erklären.
Vielleicht seid ihr Fifed genug, genug Prime-Subscribed heute schon.
IQ ist explodiert hier im Chat.
Also vielleicht könnt ihr mir das erklären.
Wer ist bei Reddit auf die Idee gekommen, dass es eine gute Idee ist,
die Inhalte, auf die es ankommt bei Reddit, nur noch zu 50% auf der Seite anzuzahlen?
Guckt euch, altes Reddit, fast alles Inhalte.
Neues Reddit, Hälfte der Seite nur noch Inhalte.
Und das Wichtigste, Kommentare in Reddit kannst du ja teilweise nicht mal richtig sehen,
weil du 50 mal ausklappen musst.
Ich versteh's einfach nicht, wie die das seit Jahren so verkacken.
Das ist ja auch nicht wirklich merklich besser geworden.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich verstehe, warum sie die Webseite modern gebaut haben.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Aber warum man das Design macht, dass die Inhalte nur 50% einnehmen, das verstehe ich nicht.
... Monstrosität, die in Megabyte von Trackern loadet
und meinen Browser verletzt, je nachdem, wie ich zu ihm navigiere.
Und die alte Version von Reddit war perfekt in Ordnung.
Also warum mussten sie es jetzt fast komplett unverwendbar machen?
Selbst einfache Informationswebseiten, wie News-Webseiten oder Rezepte-Webseiten
sind so verpackt mit so vielen Skripten,
dass es Minuten dauert, um eine einfache Webseite zu laden.
Und also...
Naja, ohne Adblocker geht's ja prinzipiell schon mal nicht.
In diesem Video möchte ich darüber nachdenken, wie das passiert ist.
Also, die einfachste Antwort auf einiges von dem ist
die aktuellen Obsessions der Webseite mit Javascript.
Natürlich gibt es nichts falsch mit Javascript.
Die Leute mögen sich auf Javascript verlieren.
Ja.
Das ist eher das geilste Bild davon.
Javascript viel.
Aber inhaltlich gibt es nichts wirklich falsch damit.
Wenn du irgendeine Art von Interaktivität auf deiner Webseite haben willst,
wirst du es benutzen.
Aber das Problem kam wirklich mit der Popularität von Javascript-Frameworks.
Also, vielleicht habt ihr gehört von React, Angular, Vue
und vielen, vielen weiteren Frameworks wie diesem.
Das sind grundsätzlich Tools, die Web-Developer benutzen,
die viele Dinge im Entwicklungsbereich abstraktieren,
um es einfacher zu machen,
um reichere, dynamische Web-Applikationen zu schaffen.
Ja.
Also, was ich eigentlich sage, ist...
Aber ich würde es gar nicht als Problem sehen.
Ich meine im Ernst,
so moderne Webseiten,
die würdest du ja nicht mit jQuery bauen.
Oder meint irgendjemand...
Irgendjemand würde gerne Draw.io mit jQuery bauen.
Ich glaube doch eher nicht.
Also, die Webseiten sind umfangreicher geworden,
haben mehr Funktionalität,
was auch dank der Frameworks ist,
weil du die Funktionalität bzw. die Komplexität
damit besser handeln kannst.
Ja, jQuery ist immer noch auf so vielen Seiten.
Ich glaube, die Top 50% der Welt haben noch jQuery.
Ja, also für mich ist es hauptsächlich das Web-Design,
was mich aktuell nervt.
Wenn quasi Webseiten sich auf dem Desktop rein
für Tablets und Smartphones anfühlen.
Diese JavaScript-Frameworks ermöglichen
sehr interaktive Web-Apps mit vielen bewegenden Teilen.
Und das ist grundsätzlich, was sie dafür benutzt werden.
Denn das am meisten populäre React
wurde ursprünglich von Facebook entwickelt.
Und das ist, weil es sehr schwer ist,
eine Webseite mit dem Niveau der Komplexität
die Facebook hat,
ohne ein komplexes JavaScript-Framework zu benutzen.
Ja.
Und diese JavaScript-Frameworks
funktionieren am besten als Einzel-Päge...
Er hat sich ein bisschen genervt an irgendwie, oder?
...Applications.
Also, das sind grundsätzlich Webseiten,
die man erwarten würde,
um zu verhalten wie Applikationen.
Also, für etwas wie ein Admin-Dashboard
ist es sinnvoll, eine von diesen Frameworks zu benutzen.
Denn du wirst ständig etwas kreieren
und ein- und ausdrucken
und du willst nicht,
dass die Seite jedes Mal wieder öffnet,
wenn du eine Aktion machst.
Das wäre sehr anstrengend, sehr schnell.
Und also funktionieren diese Frameworks am besten
für Webseiten,
die ein gewisses mittleres Interaktivitätsniveau haben.
Das ist so der süße Ort
für diese JavaScript-Frameworks.
Aber das Problem kommt darin,
wie breit die Adoption
dieser JavaScript-Frameworks war.
Nun, schau, einige dieser Webseiten
machen Sinn,
wenn sie etwas wie React benutzen.
...React, aber sobald...
Ja, benutzen anscheinend auch React.
Okay.
...cooking websites were using React,
news websites were using React,
Reddit is now using React
and none of these websites
really need to use React.
The front end of these websites
doesn't really need to be that complex.
But the reason why React
and these other JavaScript-Frameworks
really took the Internet by storm
is because of how they were marketed.
So basically, whenever...
Naja, also Marketing allein
ist es sicherlich nicht.
Entwickler entwickeln halt einfach gerne
mit einem ordentlichen JavaScript-Framework
anstatt mit jQuery.
Und das muss auch nicht pauschal schlecht sein.
Dass viele Webseiten komplett sinnlos
plottet sind und sich drauf verlassen,
dass jeder heute mindestens vier Kerne hat
und zwei Gigabyte RAM frei für die Anwendung
ist was anderes.
Aber so ein JavaScript-Framework
würde ich sogar mal so weit gehen und sagen,
ist meistens nicht das Problem
dafür, wenn die Webseite scheiße ist.
Das ist das nächste größte Ding in Webentwicklung.
Und wenn du mal ein Webentwickler warst,
ich meine, auch jetzt,
bist du eigentlich ein Idiot,
wenn du keinen dieser neuen Frameworks benutzt.
Du bist fast im Vergangenen.
Und wenn du immer noch in etwas wie PHP arbeitest,
lachen die Leute an dir.
Und diese neuen Frameworks
sind nicht unbedingt besser als die alte Art,
wie die Leute das gemacht haben.
Es ist eher nur Peer-Pressure,
weil alle anderen das machen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das Peer-Pressure ist.
Das ist, weil du mit einem ordentlichen
Frontend-Framework einfach viel angenehmer
Webanwendungen bauen kannst,
als mit reinem vanilla JavaScript
oder jQuery.
Ja, das ist die GitHub-Umfrage,
die Stackoverflow-Umfrage,
die ist ein bisschen blöd gestellt.
Da geht es allgemein nicht um Frontend-Frameworks,
sondern um Frontend-Technologien
und da kannst du auch für NPM abstimmen
und sowas.
Ja.
WordPress-MonkaS.
Zwölft-Beste.
Da ist ja auch was dran.
Wenn du dich nie mit
neuen Technologien beschäftigst,
dann wirst du auch left-behind irgendwann.
Wichtig ist ja,
es ist ja nicht unbedingt sinnvoll,
immer auf das Neueste für die nächste App
aufzuspringen und das immer im Neuesten zu machen,
aber sich ein bisschen damit auszukennen
und zu wissen, wann man was am besten
benutzt und die beste Technologie
für den Anwendungsfall ist.
Das ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Wenn man einfach nur stur HTML, CSS macht
und vanilla JavaScript,
dann ist vieles gar nicht gescheit auf die Reihe.
Ohne, dass du das Rad neu erfinden musst.
Also,
weiß nicht,
irgendwie stimme ich dem Ganzen
nicht so richtig zu bis jetzt.
Ja, gut.
Oh, nice, Leute.
Das ist doch WordArt, oder?
Ja, gut.
Das musst du nicht wirklich
mit React machen,
da gebe ich ihm schon recht.
Ich glaube,
Chico braucht auch unbedingt
ihre eigene Webseite.
Ja.
Gut.
Das ist ja auch
ein bisschen das Problem,
was Single-Page-Applications
haben, die brauchen beim ersten Mal
halt ein bisschen und
die Suchmaschinen können sie nicht ordentlich indizieren.
Also insofern, ja.
Deswegen ist der neueste Trend ja
das Gegenteil davon.
Also nicht das Gegenteil,
so ein Hybrid daraus.
Server-Side-Rendering mit
Client-Side-Hydration.
Also,
du renderst die Seite initial auf dem
Server, packst den JavaScript-State ein,
Frontend pickt den State ab
und macht weiter. Dann kannst du interaktive Sachen,
dynamische Webseiten und
Suchmaschinen-Indizierung und schnelle Ladezeiten
zusammen
verwenden. Das ist so der aktuelle Trend.
JavaScript ist Single-Thread,
du hast sowas wie Web-Worker,
wo das ein bisschen
aufgeweicht ist, aber prinzipiell ist
die Frontend-Geschichte,
die Interaktion, das ist alles Single-Threaded.
Allerdings mit
IO-Callbacks quasi,
oder generell mit Callbacks. Also wenn du
auf irgendwas warten musst,
kannst du es beispielsweise mit
Async-Await machen,
dann springt das an die Stelle
zurück beim nächsten
Schleifendurchlauf, wenn es fertig
sein sollte. Ja, aber es ist Single-Threaded.
Ja, so ist es halt.
Deswegen, Leute, deswegen
Svelte benutzen.
Ist nicht umsonst
most-loved-JavaScript-Framework
bei Stackoverflow.
Google möchte
DRM in Chrome einbauen.
Ist doch schon lange.
Oder mal wieder
Manifest 3 jetzt.
Deswegen ist es
wichtig, dass es Firefox immer weiter gibt.
Ja gut,
hey Leute,
ein NPM-Install ist generell
immer eine schlechte Idee. Egal welches Projekt
du hast, die Abhängigkeiten
laden Abhängigkeiten, laden Abhängigkeiten, laden
Abhängigkeiten, du kriegst 30 Milliarden
Deprecated Warnings, das ist normal.
Also
ein Node-Folder unter 8 GB
ist kein ordentlich ernstzunehmendes
JavaScript-Projekt.
Das lädt immer das halbe Internet runter.
Das ist ja Standard schon.
In Tech these days people like to move fast
and break things, and so
while I was working on this project, they upgraded
to version 2 of Gatsby
and switching to it was a major
headache because there were so many incompatibilities
between the two versions.
I essentially had to completely rewrite my
website, and this is just
kind of the feel of working with these
modern web frameworks.
Everything's always changing and you constantly
need to be on top of things.
Ja, das stimmt.
Da hat er nicht Unrecht.
You're not going to break, you're just going to have to rewrite things
and fix things, because
there's so many moving parts in your website
that you need to pull in all of these dependencies
from all different kinds of people,
so even just a basic Hello World
example these days, at least
for Gatsby, this framework I
was working in at the time, it brings
in like a thousand packages
and all of these packages add up to
hundreds of megabytes
just to create this very basic Hello
World example.
523 MB
Node-Modules, das ist ja noch
lightweight.
Ridiculous.
And you can imagine what happens when
websites are so complex,
they really become fragile.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass deine
Output-Webseite 500 MB ist,
dein Node-Modules-Ordner ist 500 MB.
Das eine hat mit dem anderen jetzt erstmal so
gar nichts zu tun.
A lot of these projects, if you come back a year or two later
and try to download them again
and edit something with it,
it literally doesn't work because
everything has changed, like the
Node.js version has changed
and so it's no longer compatible
with all of these old libraries
and if you upgrade some of these libraries,
then they're incompatible with other libraries.
It's really a major headache working
with all of these frameworks because there are so many
moving parts, but
with everything I've told you, you might now be
wondering why anybody would want to use
these complex frameworks.
Naja,
das ist doch ganz
klar.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Leute sagen,
ich muss das jetzt benutzen, weil es hip ist,
vielleicht auch ein bisschen, sondern weil
vieles damit schlicht und ergreifend deutlich
einfacher ist als mit Vanilla JavaScript.
Mach mal mit
Vanilla JavaScript so eine Sache wie
du hast eine Inputbox
und du willst einfach nur eine Überschrift
damit aktualisieren. Ja, ist nicht
kompliziert, aber es ist schon
nicht so einfach. Du musst
dich subscriben zum Input-Event,
du musst die Tastendinger rausfiltern,
du musst neues HTML generieren,
appenden an irgendwas.
Das ist deutlich komplizierter als
eine Input zu machen, eine Textbox zu machen
und per Data Binding
das da mit einem Callback
dran zu hängen mit irgendeinem x-beliebigen
Frontend-Framework. Von da
wird es immer nur noch komplexer.
Get element by
ID und so. Ja, ist so.
Also damit ist einfach
angenehmer zu arbeiten.
Like, it might make sense if you have
a complex web application that has
a lot of interactivity,
but most websites using these bloated frameworks
don't meet these descriptions at all.
One big reason why
a lot of people use these frameworks
is the so-called developer experience.
So this is kind of a marketing term
that a lot of these frameworks
throw out. And so what this
essentially is, is it's the most
fun technology for developers to use.
That's really what the developer
experience boils down to.
Because when you use one of these frameworks
it does a lot of nice things for you.
Like I said, it does things like
minify your JavaScript, minify your CSS.
These days with every
framework you can have hot reloading
so you make one change to the website
in development and it instantly updates
while you're working on it.
If you had been like me and been making
websites the old way for a decade before
then the first time you use a
JavaScript framework it seems almost magical.
Das stimmt, da gebe ich ihm recht.
You can easily import
snippets and libraries from millions
of npm packages with a simple
terminal command. And the idea
is that if you make things easier for developers
then it's going to kind of trickle
down into a better user experience.
If we can develop new features
faster, of course that will make everything
better for the users, right?
Not only that, but working in decades
old technology is boring and
the newest framework trending on Twitter
is much more appealing than
using what you always have.
Ja, da mache ich mich auch immer lustig drüber.
Sobald du ein neues Projekt generierst
Frontend-Projekt hast du erstmal
5 Ordner und 30
Config-Files und das ist schon weird-champig
ein bisschen, ja.
Das stimmt irgendwo.
Da kann ich jetzt nichts gegen sagen.
Aber ich meine, dafür ist man dann
um irgendwie Frontend-Entwickler und sich ein bisschen
da auszukennen. So kompliziert
ist beispielsweise ein minimals
Weltkit-Projekt auch nicht.
It can also be fun to imagine yourself.
Dafür kannst du dann das Weltkit verwenden, was
sehr viele Sachen
einfacher macht.
Using the cutting edge technology that a
startup would be using.
Like, maybe you got a job at the New York Times
an old dusty newspaper
but you wish you were working at Twitter
So you use all of the cool new
technology. Ich glaube aktuell wischt kaum einer
bei Twitter zu arbeiten.
And so if all of these tools are making
the developers more efficient
what's wrong with that?
Of course all of this comes at a cost
and probably the biggest cost is performance.
And I'm sure you've heard that
if your website is slow then you're probably going
to lose business. Because
if you're a customer that's going to your website
for the first time and it's very slow to load
and very laggy
Of course people aren't going to stay on your website
for very long.
But these kinds of performance...
Naja gut, das Bilderladen, das liegt jetzt
nur beim besten Willen nicht an React, dass das so lahm ist.
...aggressions aren't really felt
until much later, until it's actively
hurting the business.
Because whenever you first use these frameworks
Ja, Webpack ist auch abfuck.
They feel pretty fast
until you have to load in all of the
dependencies and all of the
ads and traffic...
Das finde ich am angenehmsten.
...that are also required on your website
and after you add in everything
it really slows the website to a
crawl. But let's also talk about
who this affects because
let's face it...
Ja, wenn die Bilder lahm laden, das liegt nicht an dem
JavaScript Framework.
...are using M1 MacBook Pro
with 16 gigabytes of RAM
So that's on the developer side of things
These are the people in Silicon Valley
California
Also, jetzt mal ernsthaft
Ich muss ja
was erzählen. Also
Ich hab schon Frontends gebaut
mit
Ich glaub damals
war es noch Vue.js. Nee, Svelte
Sogar mit Svelte
Für ESP32 Microcontroller
Also die mussten klein sein
die mussten da drauf passen
und backend-mäßig ging da auch nicht
so viel. Klar, natürlich kann
ich auch ein komplexes Frontend ausliefern
von einem ESP32, was
einen Achtkerner in die Knie zwingt
irgendwie
Aber das Framework ist meistens
nicht so sehr das Problem. Eher das, was damit
gemacht wird
Und dadurch, dass du mit Vanilla JavaScript
und ein bisschen jQuery sehr viel
from scratch neu erfinden musst
wenn du was Interaktives machen willst
glaub ich nicht
dass es wirklich so viel besser
werden würde, nur weil du es von
Hand baust, wenn du eben eine gewisse
Funktionalität im Kopf hast, wie du es
haben willst
Svelte-Kit zu deployen ist
eigentlich relativ easy. Du kannst
entweder das Ganze statisch
generieren lassen
wenn du
Seiten vorgerendert ausliefern willst
oder du schaltest diese ganze
serverseitige Geschichte einfach ab
Also wenn du nicht serverseitig
rendern möchtest, kannst du es einfach
abschalten, dann wird das ganz normal
vom Webserver ausgeliefert und läuft kleinseitig
Also
ok, da hat er recht
Wir haben in Deutschland aber auch nicht
the fastest Internet
Und ich bin mir nicht so wirklich sicher, ob die meisten Leute
als Zielgruppe
User aus Afrika
bei ihrem
Inlineskate-Webshop
in Deutschland haben, zum Beispiel
Also
naja, naja
Es ist schon ein bisschen was dran
Und
ich sehe das ja auch ein
dass manche Webseiten
unnötig bloated sind
Ja, mach
Facebook auf, läd erstmal 18 MB Javascript
runter und sag
muss das alles sein?
Aber das kannst du
schlecht den Javascript-Frameworks
in die Schuhe schieben
Die Javascript-Frameworks sind entstanden, weil es
Probleme zu lösen gilt
und nicht umgedreht
Also es ist nicht so, dass zuerst das Javascript-Framework
da war und deswegen ist alles
schlecht geworden, sondern es gab Probleme
die sich mit der bestehenden Technologie nicht gut
haben unter einen Hut bringen lassen und daraufhin
wurden dann so Sachen wie React,
Vue, Angular und jetzt später
das Feld erst entwickelt, um manche
Sachen besser handeln zu können
Also das ist so ein bisschen falsch rum gedreht
Äh, nö
Aber ich will nicht ausschließen
dass es
ein Ding ist
Wobei ich ganz stark davon ausgehe
dass iOS und Safari
und bestimmt auch Android
solche Webseiten erkennt
und standardmäßig
drosselt
was irgendwelche Tickrates
von Javascript und sowas angeht
und spätestens wenn du den Tab zumachst
Ja, aber okay
Aber da kann das Javascript
auch nichts dafür, wenn die Webseite
einen kompletten CPU-Core voll macht
Das liegt nicht an dem Javascript-Framework
Ja
Und deswegen ist der neuste Trend ja auch
Server-Side-Rendering, Hydration
plus Javascript-Frontend
Dass du so Oldschool
und Newschool miteinander sinnvoll
verbinden kannst
Und ich glaube auch, dass das quasi so
für Jahre lang jetzt so der
immer weiter der Stand der Technik
werden wird
Es wird wirklich
der Stand der Technik
werden
Es wird weggehen von reinem
Server-Side-Rendering
bei denen, die es noch machen
Es wird weggehen von reinen PWA's
für die, die es noch machen
zu so einer Full-Stack-Geschichte
aus Server-Side-Rendering
plus Javascript-Frontend
Das ist auch eine sinnvolle
Das ist eigentlich die logische
Schlussfolgerung aus der ganzen Sache
Du renderst die Webseite
Server-seitig vor
Du hast schnelle Load-Time
Du kannst die Webseite besonders schnell laden
Und du kannst interaktive Sachen machen
Du kannst die Webseite durchsuchbar machen
von Crawlern, von Suchmaschinen
Also SSR mit Hydration und Frontend
Javascript, das wird sich durchsetzen
Das hat sich schon durchgesetzt
und wird auch immer weiter
der Standard werden
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht
Ja, das ist sicherlich bei manchen
Webseiten, die scheiße gemacht sind
Und ob die besser wären
wenn die die Leute manuell mit
jQuery zusammengewurstet hätten
Da habe ich wirklich meine Zweifel
Ich bin definitiv nicht der Erste
der das bemerkt
Aber als Webdeveloper
möchte ich eigentlich die Webseite
Ich glaube sogar YouTube
Ich glaube YouTube verwendet weder React
noch Angular noch sonst was
Und das ist auch lahmes Fuck oftmals
Besser
Und es ist ein bisschen Licht am Ende des Tunnels
Denn viele neuere Tools
sind anfangs weg zu gehen von der Idee
dass alles eine Einzel-Seite-App ist
Ja, sage ich ja
Das ist auch der aktuelle Trend
und das wird auch in Zukunft weiterhin zunehmen
Kids
den komischen Thermostat rumgebastelt, das fand ich übelst langweilig.
Das stimmt wohl, also alles, was Webpack verwendet, ist ppga und kann man ja jetzt fast
an User-Bullshit.
Webpack ist wirklich eines der schlimmsten Sachen überhaupt.
Das ist wenig.
Is there any better, more efficient way to build what I'm thinking about?
And so that's how I got to the current state of the web.
And my dream is that someday I will be able to browse Reddit without having to crash my browser.
Maybe someday. I can dream, right?
Also ich finde das aber jetzt alles etwas überdramatisiert.
Ich sehe eher das Problem im immer nervig werdenden Webdesign für Desktop-User
So wie Endless-Scroll und so ein Shit, was keine Sau braucht auf dem Desktop.
Ja, da sehe ich eher das Problem.
Nun gut, jetzt wissen wir, warum JavaScript das Web ruiniert hat.
Ich habe da einiges anders gesehen als eher im Video.
iOS 17 Top Features
Okay, Sekunde, Sekunde. Gibt es da so viele geile neuen Features?
Wurde vor einem Monat vorgestellt und eigentlich wollte ich dieses Video schon viel eher machen, aber
Frage. Nö, gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Irgendwie kam ich nicht wirklich dazu.
Jetzt habe ich es endlich geschafft. iOS 17 ist auf meinem iPhone installiert und getestet worden.
Und das hier sind meine sieben Lieblings-Features.
Okay, auf geht's. Timer.
Das wohl beste Feature ist wohl die Möglichkeit nun endlich mehrere Timer gleichzeitig zu haben.
Oh mein Gott, Apple hat sich wieder selbst übertroffen.
Stellen.
Okay, das wohl so ziemlich
Das einzige, was mich an iOS 17-Antrag so richtig begeistert hat, war die Standby-Funktion.
Damit könnt ihr euer iPhone abends in eine super-smarte Nachttischuhr verwandeln.
Damit kann man rein theoretisch sogar ein HomePod ersetzen.
Ähm, das ist das erste, was ich abgeschaltet habe.
Das mir nämlich auch aufgefallen bei meinem neuen iPhone, dass es jetzt, wenn ich es sperre,
den Bildschirm nur noch freest oder dunkler macht, anstatt es komplett auszuschalten.
Das war das erste, was ich ausgeschaltet habe.
Und das circa mit einem Display.
Und ich sag's euch, je mehr ich es genutzt habe, desto geiler fand ich das Ganze.
Es ist nicht einfach nur eine simple Uhr oder ein Kalender, die Daten anzeigen können,
sondern das liegt daran, dass die Widgets auf iOS 17 endlich nun nicht mehr einfach nur hübsche, dumme Rechtecke sind,
die am Ende eigentlich nichts anderes sind als Icons, die absolut nichts können,
sondern sie können auch wie bei Android nun endlich angetippt und vernünftig bedient werden.
Damit kann ich dann zum Beispiel über die Standby-Funktion Checklisten abhaken,
smarte Automation aktivieren oder Lichter bedienen.
Okay. Ja. Ja, okay. Ich gette das, dass das für manche sicherlich cool sein wird.
Ich hab Siri gar nicht an.
Doch, stimmt, ich hab Siri an. Das ist für Carplay-Voraussetzungen, witzigerweise.
Aber ich hab dieses Listen, ständige Listen nicht an.
Was ich auch einfach nur hammer cool finde, ist, dass Apple auch daran gedacht hat,
einen Nachtmodus zu implementieren. Sobald die Umgebung nämlich dunkel wird,
wird das Display automatisch abgedunkelt und alles erscheint in einem dunklen Rotton,
wie man es auch bei der Apple Watch Ultra kennt.
Der Standfuß, den Apple auf der Keynote vorgestellt hat, ist nicht zwingend notwendig.
Man könnte auch rein theoretisch einfach das hier machen.
Wer von euch...
Man könnte das iPhone auch einfach neben auf den Schrank legen oder irgendwo unter das Kisten oder...
Bei meinen Freunden und mir ist es so, dass jeder von uns jeweils einige AirTags besitzen,
die wir auch an Dinge rankleben, die uns beide gehören, wie zum Beispiel diese süße kleine Maus hier.
Das Problem ist, wenn ein AirTag bei dir ist, was nicht auf deinen Namen registriert ist,
bekommst du aus Sicherheitsgründen eine Benachrichtigung,
dass ein AirTag in deiner Nähe sich befindet, was nicht dir gehört.
Das hat jetzt natürlich Riesenvorteile, wie zum Beispiel sich vor Stalkers zu schützen.
Das ganze Problem um dieses Thema habe ich bereits in einem...
AirTags befinden sich in der Nähe, die nicht dir gehören.
Ah! Wenn dich irgendeiner tracken will mit AirTags, dann wird das jetzt angezeigt oder so.
Okay.
Dass es einfach auf den Keks geht.
Ja.
Ein bisschen runter.
Sag Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Okay.
Geht das jetzt erst?
Dachte, du konntest deine Kontakte schon ewig sharen.
Über AirDrop.
Ja, ich dachte, das geht schon lange.
Okay, aber vielleicht nicht mit so einem coolen Visitenkartenbild und sowas.
Ja, gut.
Okay.
Ich hab, by the way, ich hab AirDrop aus.
Ich schalte es immer nur ein, wenn ich mal irgendwie was hin und her schieben muss.
Okay.
Und, und dann?
Na, da habe ich aber schon bessere synthetische Stimmen-AI-Sachen gehört in den letzten Monaten.
Okay.
Ich nicht.
Ich finde Textnachrichten, Nachrichten viel angenehmer, als wenn mich jemand anruft.
Die sollen mir nicht auf den Sack gehen.
Na, Textnachricht reicht.
Aha.
Na dann.
So mega gehypt hat es mich jetzt nicht.
Oh nein!
Einer, der keinen Bock mehr auf NeoWim hat.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Nice.
Das ist ein guter Name für eine Eisdiele.
Ja, erstmal das halbe Internet runterladen.
Express kommt da jetzt.
Express braucht halt irgendwie drei Gigabyte Javascript oder so.
Okay.
Oh, schlechte Idee.
Schlechte Idee.
Okay, ich gette den Gag, ja.
Da gibt es ja dieses Meme-Build schon ewig mit Node-Modules, Blackhole, heaviest objects in the universe.
Sun, Neutronenstern, schwarzes Loch, Node-Modules.
So, Leute.
Was gibt es heute zu essen?
Ratet mal.
Und ihr werdet wahrscheinlich richtig liegen.
Lachs mit Nudel, korrekt.
Lachs mit Nudel gibt es heute.
So sieht es aus.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
CU.